I think like the the process that I was
going through was the idea of like I
actually was upset at myself because I
knew of this person's behavior and I
didn't bet on myself right I bet on when
other people said give this person a
chance they're not like what you and I
let this person do my [__] they did
right and they I have to take personal
responsibility for that now
three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of The Genius
brain podcast we have one of my favorite
people on this Earth we got Megan
Mitchell let's go making a heart with my
wine glass we haven't had Megan on this
podcast in about two years it's been a
hot second but you know I always love uh
bringing people on that I [__] with not
a lot of new people come around here
just because why I don't want to talk to
you you don't like me I don't like you
[__] it you know what I'm saying Megan
Have You Been I'm
been okay it's been a rough two years
it's been rough it's been rough what's
going on with you
oh what isn't I feel like I mean the
last time we were on the last time we
were on it was all about
racism which sorry racism is still
around in two years but I think I moving
into a space of really using my voice to
Advocate which I really might give you
credit for because you're the person
that like made me actually confront and
say these things out loud and then once
I say them out loud you know you can't
be done with them but it's exhausting
like I miss the days of just having to
like worry about going to Louie and
buying my purses and where I'm gonna eat
now it's like still that yeah right
still that because I am who I is who I
is but is coupled with exhaustion from
having to
navigate spaces that are so centered
around whiteness that even if it is in a
space of advocacy it's still centered
around whiteness you know and I do
understand when when people say
uh
like I don't like it when other people
get on other people's cases of like how
come you're not speaking up at every
turn it's like do you know do you have
any how exhausting that's exhausting so
when other people write these posts of
oh why didn't you say this why didn't
you say that some people just can't deal
with it it's exhausting to do with that
24 7. and is it always going to be your
responsibility to go ahead and check
somebody some people have social anxiety
like how how do you always do this I I
like to do it in gradients right there's
some people a lot some people don't
agree with this but once you hit past
the age of 80
let God be with you you're gonna meet
him soon anyways yeah no I I agree and
you've already done your time like what
like John Lewis literally dedicated his
whole life
to civil rights at what point does he
get to enjoy his life like when
and there are people too where I'll meet
there are 80 something Euro they say
some highly offensive stuff racially
right and I'm just like you're gonna be
dead in 10 years you're not going to
affect the future this is just your
little bubble I'll let you have it
what's the whole point of this right I
agree and I think sometimes which sounds
crazy but I agree with that too
right because it's not like if if they
have an encountered first off I think
the thing that people have to understand
is people have to want to change so if
you spent 80 years on this planet 80
years
thinking the same if you think black
people are trash and unworthy and you
spend 80 years thinking that the only
person that's going to stop you from
thinking that is the Lord Jesus himself
yeah so you mosion and I let Jesus deal
with you because I'm not gonna waste my
time there like what am I gonna do it's
the hardest part uh sometimes too with a
with a younger generation because now
we're so
we just live on the internet so much
that it's hard to tell somebody who's
younger than you that you can't base
humans off of what you see on the
internet and the things that you read
you have to interact with and to see for
yourself that's been their whole life
yeah so people so when you see like this
small because I'll say this right I go
Twitter is or how many people are on the
internet whatever the percentages
somebody could find it out there for me
but it's definitely not 50 and I think
it's below 30 right so if you base all
of Humanity on the small percentage of
people who use the internet then on top
of that the smaller percentage of people
who use Twitter Youtube and everything
else
and you're really not going to get to
know people at all some of the worst
people the people with the most anxiety
some [__] to say that'll never say to
your face what the [__] are they doing
they're going online
you know Drake said it trigger fingers
turn to Twitter fingers like that is the
and I try to tell my students this all
the time I'm like first off y'all have
to realize certain things one y'all are
really young which means that you're
going to make a lot of mistakes the
difference between you and I is the
internet wasn't around or that
accessible when I was making those
mistakes right like definitely was
probably talking to some pedophiles in
an AOL chat room yeah right where it's
like ASL but that's as far as them wet
yeah you know like what was I my cousin
and I were just
um no no one of my girlfriends oh we
just got back from Mexico so on the way
back mind you that was amazing but
getting through cut crazy this is so
ghetto yeah um but we were talking and
she was literally saying something about
um we were singing a line from something
and the line was like
um
something about oh we were singing
Computer Love and it was like
um is that your face I see on my
computer screen I was like when that
song came out my juice like the 80s so
that was like hella futuristic I'm like
now I carry around basically a mini
computer yeah yeah I can easily like
talk to somebody face to face and don't
even think twice about it right but for
me or for us right we also remember a
time with ASL with dial-up with forget
Diaz like forget DSL right we're talking
about like the old days of AOL where
there were no pictures like you
literally would just meet people and be
like age sex location and straight up
you could not use the phone in your
house because if you did it would [__]
up the internet don't let your mama or
Daddy pick up the phone because then
you're not getting back online for an
hour the amount of ass whoopings I got
because my parents would try to call
somebody but they've heard that the
idiot and then my parents would come in
what the [__] are you doing
and then it would just be an [__] my
mom didn't care she would literally be
dialing I'm like Mommy
[__] we had to
if I wanted an album that I wanted to
download that was a two-day ordeal today
well actually let me tell you something
by the time Napster hit and LimeWire
were hidden yeah like my mom being a
teacher had upgraded our
um our landline our DSL so that thing so
she got a whole separate phone line for
it you can tell me nothing that's crazy
like had a whole separate phone line so
we could just
and then it you know it took six hours
but best believe it wasn't two days ago
best believe it wasn't two days yep when
that Country Grammar dropped I had it my
last I remember just going through like
heartbreak and
I would just it would just be Boys to
Men Brian McKnight Jodeci all this
[__] sad ass [__] music and I
would have this like breakup CD mixes
y'all don't even know about that stuff
you got your little Spotify mixes we had
seeds we were the curators of our own
mixes you could have just typed in a
song like you had to like think okay
what is the beginning of this gonna look
like what is the end and then don't let
a song be over the amount of time on the
CD that you're trying to burn because
then you either that was always a
struggle for me because I was like dang
I'm either gonna be short one song that
I'm a no it's shortest song because I'm
the one that made this mix or it's gonna
cut off in the middle of the song we had
the breakup mix we had the cruising mix
right I had the [__] I had all of
these these were literally the titles of
all my CDs yeah all my mixes and then
you open up your big uh remember the CD
case
and when your car had a six CD changer
yo that was it was done it was you were
the [__] car that everybody wanted to
get into because we didn't have to flip
[__] out we're like yo just switch the
CD switch the CD but that's why I really
do think that we know so many literature
songs we have a lot of emotional
connection to music there's not to say
that young people don't but then you
guys get to cycle through so many things
you don't get to sit without they don't
get to sit with it like I was again
talking to my students you want to feel
old become a teacher I was talking to my
students and
I actually posted on Instagram because
I'm ghetto so I was like 21 and then
they were like can you do some for me so
we were like and I asked him I was like
what's your um
oh just reach I was like what's your
favorite song on the album
do you know they were like I don't know
the album
I was like what do you mean on the album
first of all F Drake
for coming at Mega stallion took me a
very long time to thank you brother to
listen to the album because I'm like
first of all Aubry you stay placating
towards black with me always talk about
how you like thick women you always talk
about how you love black women and then
we we all saw your baby mama bro but you
know bye guys it's whatever's profitable
but I was like y'all don't listen to the
whole album
they don't listen to the whole album
like they legitimately do not listen to
the whole album I had a friend of mine
he's a DJ right and he said that he saw
somebody who blew up off of tick tock
and his song
hundreds of millions of spins right so
you would think that from the song they
would listen to his whole album so no
he's performing his [__] he has a whole
discography of people aren't moving Jam
nothing to his music just quiet just
like I don't know what the [__] this is
and I'm talking about this guy probably
put his heart and soul into his album
and then the song that's on Tick Tock
that's popular comes out everybody's
jumping they're super hype crazy but the
amount of disrespect for this artist
because they actually don't give a [__]
about this person
the catchiness of the song The Jingle of
the song but that's why we have so many
one-hit wonders nowadays or that's how
we have so many people going viral like
back in our oh we oh cause I was gonna
say back in our day yeah
you had to have a full album right like
by the time we switch from cassette
tapes to CDs you can buy singles anymore
so your whole album had to hit if I'm
going to spend 15.99 I have to have uh
no finisher from the start to the Finish
like I had to be able to listen to the
album through I have to be able to I
mean but even think about the way that
music videos were service to us yeah
right like we used to call and vote like
it was a big deal if you were number one
on 106 and Parker number one or TRL
because we actually have to call in and
support you so I think that's why the
level of support that we see for artists
now is different as well right like
people like
hmm
I'm trying to think Drake actually I
feel like is one of the last
performers or last artist that will
forever have an audience and a brand and
I say that because
he was hot off of his mixtapes yeah yeah
you know but even if you think about
like Kanye like oh my gosh
damn I miss I miss Kanye so much and I'm
gonna tell you why I miss Kanye is
because I was a true Kanye fan like I
had the mixtapes the freaking mixtape
100 I mean on the Louis Vuitton down
like I had all of them Drake was the
same way right like he got hot off of
his mixtapes had singles out no record
deal
you can't have that now like did you see
that the artists aren't good but they're
just not like they're I feel like they
all are gonna have their their time to
shine and then it's gonna phase out and
the new person's gonna come back in I
mean that's what's always happening like
I give people like a cycle of five six
years and then people move on and they
find the next hottest thing people don't
really sit with the with the art anymore
and also too some of these new artists
don't really consider themselves artists
as yourself so you know they're not
until I'm not exactly so they'll make
their bag and they'll move on which I
guess is fine right I hope they invest
in no they're definitely not a lot of
them aren't like I mean of course I mean
you're super young you come with all
this money what are you gonna do with it
right because if I was 17 16 years old
what the [__] am I gonna do with [__]
I don't know six seven million dollars I
don't know blow that [__] and they they
just never know it's even like that with
a lot of like uh YouTubers
um when I was starting out and I used to
see these guys roll up with just the
craziest [__] right the Louis backpack
right with uh it would be like [__]
five six grand they got this Rolly on
their wrist and whatever whatnot and I'm
like
I know how much money you make and I
don't see that being in your bank
account now right so I wonder what
you're doing with that right and they
were living it up and mind you I'm not
gonna lie they look [__] good they
look great they were stunting some of
the dopest [__] I've ever seen longevity
and then now they're just over here like
okay well what I got to do for money I
was like well really if you didn't spend
like 200 G's on stupid [__] you wouldn't
be worrying about that stuff right which
kind of where I put myself in my
position right I don't I'm probably
doing literally 20 amount of social
media that I used to do seven years ago
right but I make more money now than I
do then so it's like what if you
invested you have businesses like you
thought outside of the YouTube timeline
but I think we also saw this age right
where people were getting when YouTube
really started like monetizing our
influencers became a thing
that you would not believe how many
students I have that say they want to be
influencers crazy and I'm just like this
is
I know influencers so I know that
influencers do work like it is a
lifestyle like it is a commitment to
sharing everything like when I first
wake up in the morning I definitely am
not vlogging and doing a camera on my
face because I'm just you know I'm not
that person I'm not doing it no I can't
do it can't do it I literally can't do
it people are asking yo you should start
doing Vlogs again I'll sock you in your
mouth no I'm not going I'm too old for
it I'm not doing it I'm not but you're
at the point where you don't have to
right these my students I'm like
I'm definitely a supporter of all dreams
but also a realist like I'm not going to
be the teacher that crushes your dreams
but I'm also not going to be the teacher
that sends you out into the world
blindly and I told them I said you know
there's fewer YouTubers that make this
type of money
um to sustain the lifestyle that y'all
want then there are those that are
pretending yeah right because the thing
is to pretend like the bags you can rent
the bags on on varel or vivrel or
whatever or switch or backborrows or
still so you're not seeing the behind
the scenes but again like we were saying
earlier it comes down to the fact that
this is all that they know 100 so this
is like it's so crazy because I'll say
this a million times over and people
just don't believe it and I'm talking
about this is not from a hateful place
this is from a generation where I want
them to do really well because you're in
a space like this because of older
people like me who started this right
but I think they kind of fell in love
with everything but the hard work that
it took for us to get to this point
where we do get to chill a little more
you know so for example
America's parents because these are your
kids that are sitting in our classes so
I'll go to these events right and then I
see you know I'm rolling up I don't have
an expensive car anymore right I've Had
My Moments where I wanted the floss and
I let that [__] go but can you
exactly so you know I roll up I have a
forerunner it's a good car I come
through first of all your foam Runner is
fly as all hell like it is you you don't
have the base model yeah okay we're
doing what we're doing right and so I'm
rolling up and then we see this kid
these kids and I know them right I know
them because you know they have it on
this like sheet where I get to see what
these people do and I was curious about
Tick Tock at the time and also Instagram
just to see what the younger generation
is doing and some of them make good
money but then the other 95 doesn't but
that's the key and I look at this some
of them as in five percent yeah make
good money and the other 95 do not
distract and I'm looking at their page
though and just like you said they're in
like Ibiza they're traveling all over
the place and so I just wanted to talk
to them and there's you know some of
them are coming up it's like yo I
watched you since I was a kid all this
other stuff and I'm like hey cool like
how are you doing they're like man like
we're just trying to make some money
like I was like so what do you do right
now maybe you gotta get a job they all
six people live in one apartment you
gotta get a job and I'm like hold on a
second y'all end of every single one you
have over a million Tick Tock followers
you so what are you doing to leverage
that type of stuff like well they're
giving us free trips uh-huh that's what
I was like Hey dummy that's what you're
getting that's your what you should be
getting in dollars you are getting in
free trips I was like this is what you
should do right
go fly there perfectly fine but you
should be asking for money if they don't
want to give you the [__] money
that's fine ask or they don't want to
give you the fight and the money take
the money instead and then go buy the
ticket to the [__] place and you'll
still make money on top yeah they don't
get that [__] no they don't especially
if this is a business or hotel or like a
luxury travel group or something they're
making they are making a profit off of
you a hundred and if they are flying you
over and putting them in some of their
hotels and things best believe they're
not paying for all they're paying for is
the flight and they may have travel
credits so take always take from someone
who used to be in entertainment
take the money always take the [__]
money and if they don't want to give you
the money that's not a brand that you
want to partner with and you know for
for those people who want to make this
into a living right and I say this this
is not a this is not disrespectful at
all you guys are trash anyways like it's
not like you're creating art you're just
doing it for the bag right nothing you
put in out has Hearts see that put in
exactly like you don't put your heart
into it you don't give a [__] about the
[__] you put out you just want to be
famous so at least make some money off
of it you know what I'm saying like why
the [__] do you care so much about what
these people who you have never met in
your life think about the way that you
[__] live just do what you [__] do
and then if you're trying to make money
make money off of it it's not gonna
[__] last but at least make that back
last for as long as it can
that's the thing you know what I'm
saying that's the thing see people
always wonder why Megan Pete finished
her degree even though she had top
selling
um albums is because she was aware right
like there's only for so long that you
can do some of the things that you do so
I saw Janet Jackson last Friday okay
dream come true that is my like y'all
know I people know I love Beyonce but
the way I love Janet like I it wouldn't
even be a choice I'm choosing Janet
every single day fight me I don't care
yeah
um and one of the things that was like I
went with my cousin and she was like
she's covered up I was like girl she's
in her 50s you expect her to still be
out here it's just about to fall out
right like
still amazing music's I mean she was
singing live she was at the
um Five Point Amphitheater in Irvine
okay so she is live live band everything
sounded amazing dancing amazing right
but she is 50.
maybe you don't want your titties out
when you 50. I mean she already did the
Justin Timberlake thing that she had
already flopped out at that age that she
came out like a Justin but like screwed
Justin because he he knew better he knew
he knew should not have let Janet should
have not
um did the show on the court on the
curtails of a black woman but then leave
her out there to hang because she was a
bigger star you know what's crazy like I
I just I was talking to Tim about this
on our podcast where I I literally
didn't know anything about the Iggy
Azalea thing that happened uh with DC
Young Fly Right and I've only heard it
through the grave I was something I
wasn't really interested in and so I go
ahead and I read what Iggy wrote out
about DC's wife passing away she used to
be a wild outgrow you know I'm catching
up on all the old gossip and so when Tim
was giving me uh the lowdown about what
happened how awkward it [__] was and
how much he flipped out I actually
didn't realize
he was actually underplaying it to me
because when I actually saw the clip it
was it was so awkward
and I you know and I wanted to know when
Tim told me what the joke was it was
such a mild
kindergarten joke it wasn't even
specific it was very general it was such
a as a comic like DC is it was literally
a soft line he just said your ugly ass
that's it that's General you could be
ugly for whatever [__] reason he
didn't talk about anything else and then
she took it madoffensive and she goes
that's super colorist I'm like colorist
what are you talking about he just said
I was like what what is this he's
talking about
you are ugly that's it that has nothing
to do with the color of your skin
because
ugliness is something that does not
discriminate either it doesn't matter
what cultural background you're
Affiliated you're ugly ugly it's ugly
boo
ugly is ugly and it was weird like I'm
not sure if and you know what it was so
hard for me to watch I had to pause and
just continue to watch it again because
it was so real to life because we've
seen people do that where they're in a
group they won't let the joke go and
they have to keep coming back to this
[__] well that's empty like you're
not funny Let It Go and if DC wanted to
rip into you he really could have he
really could have and towards the end
he's like why do you keep coming after
me just stop please stop no that's
that's when I was like I was like this
is so awkward yeah because it's you know
we talked about being exact being
exhausted by whiteness right
okay
How can I
you know
you got a BBL to look like a black woman
um
he's looking up non-existent baby hairs
to look like a black woman
you are it is very it's always very
difficult for me for people that profit
off of Black Culture
to then try to use their white privilege
to
attack gas like gas light
um
reprimand somebody that is black right
so even wild and out wild and out was on
MTV and MTV too but is Nick Cannon like
he had he's featuring
comics of color right because Tim's not
black but Tim's is a comic of color
right it's a safe space for black people
why would you go on a show why would you
go on a show
where you know they're gonna be bagging
on you like that's the whole point of
the show is to like bag on you right she
said she didn't know tripping again so
then you're ignorant because the reason
why you came on this show specifically
is because you know that the people that
support your music and support your
platform are watching this show
but then the moment you shoot in the
dozens like everybody knows I'm somebody
that I cannot shoot the dozens I cannot
bag I'm Gonna Come Out Swinging I get my
feelings hurt yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm a
Scorpio like don't talk about my mama
don't talk about me like I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna talk about you so don't
bring it over here but you asked your
management somebody somebody knew what
the show was about
they agreed to put you on the show you
coming up there with your baby hairs in
your booty and then when DC Young Fly
says a says a joke that is like I mean
shut your ugly like that is bottom of
the barrel joke that is being kind to
her being kind boo he could have talked
about you he could have talked about
yourself
there's a lot of things he could have
said he didn't he did not and didn't
pumpkin head but then you get in this
space
and the first thing you want to do
is wave your flag of white privilege and
that is that itself is why whiteness is
exhausting it's because it's all fun and
games till you want to be white
and it was like the funny thing is you
want to talk about holding a [__]
Grudge right so DC Young Fly for those
who don't know about this his wife
passed away right tragically she passed
away it was true for some type of
cosmetic surgery whatever there is no
judgment on that either way there's no
judgment but it makes me sad though that
women especially women of black women
feel this need to
alter our natural beauty and our bodies
because she was gorgeous
I don't think there is a per not even a
man a person on this planet that would
not unanimously say that she was
gorgeous beautiful beautiful she's had
three kids
three
this Snapback culture this culture of
looking like you were when you were 20 I
didn't even appreciate the body I had
when I was 20. I was looking at a
picture when I was 29. I was like you're
a dumb hoe you was you was fly my
situation a little different when I was
29 she wouldn't not pop it but you know
but I know what you're saying no but so
the fact that she even felt the pressure
to have to go under the knife and this
is no judgment right like this is no
judgment but I just it breaks my heart
it's a conversation to have though right
absolutely and on the opposite side
right I saw this uh story from Blac
Chyna did you see what she did she went
and got hers her fillers taken out
picking out and look how beautiful she
looks gorgeous right but see Blac Chyna
was
so I'm about to tell him myself
so before Blac Chyna was Tyga's baby
mama I actually saw her
um in Miami oh really
that kld my girlfriends this is before
um you know I became a bonus mom and all
that other good stuff but she was she
was a baddie back then and when I first
saw her I was like I saw her from behind
she was wearing a pink wig I was like oh
my gosh that's Nikki because I had all
Nicki mixtapes and she turned around I
was like that's not Nikki but she is
bad like before the fillers and
everything she was just she was a like
she was beautiful like just bad right
and it's like but again
the pressure
to keep up and I feel like when you as a
black woman when you get into certain
spaces or you get into Blac Chyna was
beautiful to black people right but the
moment that she and Tangled got
entangled with the Kardashian family
then it was a whole different audience
right so then you feel the pressure to
not just look beautiful but to look
beautiful to White culture
or the masses right so that's why she
altered herself I will say this though
and you know this is for anybody in the
entertainment space where
it's it's
when you value yourself only based on
your beauty and what people see in you
based on your exterior it's going to
mean that much more to you to hold on to
this thing called youth that is supposed
to go away do this bleeding it is
supposed to [__] go away you're not
supposed to be the baddest [__] on the
Block forever or be the baddest be the
baddest in your age group yeah and also
in your age group you know what I'm
saying like it it's a negative sum right
you keep putting more into this bag that
will never give back to you at all ever
it doesn't [__] work that way right
like sometimes I have and I see it this
is a criticism specifically on Korean
culture too right
um
people fly to Korea to get their [__]
done right and I see a lot of here's
what I noticed about Japan and Korea
here's the biggest difference when I was
walking around Korea right
a lot of Korean people will never walk
outside the house not looking their best
right a lot of Korean people look very
similar because they have the same
doctor doing the same surgeries
so you go to Japan I feel like you just
called out some of my homegirls okay I
still love y'all y'all look good
you look like a bunch of cats so we have
we have a bunch
[__] ridiculous we got
oh my God that's such an insult because
we don't even like cats
when I went to Japan right
I noticed that you know we have
similarities in our culture but
everybody looked a little different
that's all
that's all nice you guys they're
torturing you first
so different like they weren't so
concerned about looking a hundred
percent when they walked outside the
door and everybody had they looked a
little more comfortable you know when I
look at Korean entertainment like you'll
see stuff like love island or whatever
what not right I love Korean
entertainment they got so much filth
they don't even look like people anymore
and I'm like that's not what you look
like there was nothing wrong with your
[__] face and it's this idea they
they want to have that Western look but
what the [__] was wrong with your face
but again right that goes back to the
exhaustion of having to try and
assimilate or live up to whiteness I
hate it and look and it's and it's
terrible it is the one thing that
frustrates me the most and this is
probably so trivial is having friends
that have that have gotten the double
eyelid surgery yeah and I'm like
and your eyes are beautiful you're
trying to get something that is not that
you were genetically not designed to
have and trust me if there's a plastic
surgeon if Dr Miami wants to offer me a
mommy makeover I'm taking it and when
you see me out here in the streets
wearing nothing don't say nothing but
but
I'm not going to ever try to do
something
that you know imma show a picture of my
body at 29 and let him make it that but
I'm not gonna take out my booty I'm not
gonna take off my titties I'm not gonna
want you to I don't want to thigh gap
like my thighs are meant to touch yeah
but it is but I've had to develop this
self-confidence because everything else
in the world right like black girl
bodies were popular when the Kardashians
had black grown body bodies now they're
going back to and I hate this term
they're going back to the heroine Chic
yeah yeah yeah yeah
I will never be heroin Chic my body is
not designed to do that so I would have
to go under the knife and alter who I
physic my body type to do that
this is what I'm saying with like uh oh
you know for those who don't know you
know you guys think that I talk a lot of
[__] about like Korean entertainment
right but I'm talking about before you
even got on the wave of Korean pop
culture whatever whatnot you got to
understand that I'm a Korean immigrant
if you don't know about h.o.t
h-o-t-s-e-s Finkel don't say about BTS
and Latino HLT exactly so we're going
back in time right and what I really
liked about that generation was that
everybody looked a little different they
did people had their own style they had
everything else and so now why I don't
care about groups like BTS or not
they're saying that they're not dope
they're not doing what they're doing but
I could pluck them out and then throw
somebody else back in and they would
look exactly the same right it doesn't
take away from what they're doing but
this is just to go not just Korean
culture right Korean pop culture anyways
and sometimes even in their society but
the reason why they're having two
westernize or feel like they have to
westernize is because they are trying to
hit the fans in America yeah and it kind
of goes back to this idea of where you
don't have to be beautiful based on
somebody else's standards right there's
something very special and unique about
what you do right
if like if everybody looked the same how
boring would life be if everybody spoke
the same language as everybody had the
same culture how boring would life be
really you just have to find that when
you have and make it beautiful make it
work for you no you will never look like
that person you will never be that other
person and that's completely okay but
you're focusing on things literally
you're planning scenes into dirt that
has no nutrition if things will not grow
from here at all as much as you want
that tomato plant to grow
there was not enough NPK in that soil to
help this tomato grow it is Clay written
first of all first of all internets Al
Gore's internet people
she just walked through my tomato garden
David has
70 000 Tomatoes listen Okay this is the
pride of his existence so the fact that
they don't even know why you're
referencing Tomatoes but I know how
important these tomatoes are to you in
your heart is ridiculous don't plant
your Tomato Seed in the soil that is not
ready for like I just I feel bad
sometimes right like I look
then first of all I have a black thumb
forget it Green Thumb I have a black
um okay so the fact that you spouting
out these gardening like this is why
you're watching uh Magnolia home is GTV
talking about Adam y'all David is fully
I'm I'm a housewife is what I am
but not a real housewife he is a real
guardian wife okay so back to your
tomato analogy
I just feel bad for this like our
generation the younger generation the
generation that comes after you where
you feel like you have to put on your
best for people who don't care about you
it is the saddest thing I've ever seen
you are putting on your best for people
who don't give a [__] about you if you
died the next day they will not mourn
you they will not cry they may shed a
single tear but the next day they'll
find and worship somebody else and it's
so hard to tell people this right like I
I posted this thing on my Instagram I
have this other Instagram where I just
simply post photos of my everyday life
when I call it my Daily Journal that's
my favorite I mean it's just my life and
I take film photography on it uh
sometimes digital but it's just what it
is I took my eat my business email off
of it I was getting all these offers I
was like you know what I don't want to
deal with this [__] this is just what I
want to share about my personal life
it's a digital [__] diary let's let
it be but it's dope though because it's
not again it's not for the masses so you
don't have to you don't have to be you
know the personality or the Persona
David you just get to be David and it
reminds me this is why I like film
photography a lot because there's some
photos that my parents have right where
I see them in their youth before I was
born even when I was younger and these
photos weren't meant for anybody else
but our family right and when sometimes
when people create they think that
they're creating you're not creating
[__] you're creating [__] repetitive
garbage what happened to the times where
we used to just take photos just for our
memories right and now we're just trying
to create memories that don't exist they
don't exist
I I see it in a lot of people who have
the most [__] up relationships right
there
you know
like look I've been around these type of
people not people in my [__] Circle
anymore but the people that used to be
in my circle they have some of the most
[__] up relationships and I see them
crying to me about how they've been how
they cheated on them how they have an
addiction to porn all this other stuff
but that same [__] day that they were
crying they're like I love my husband he
is the best nobody told you to post that
[__] photo nobody asked to see this
what are you trying to do here what are
you projecting right and the thing about
it is like when you have a certain
amount of following you do have a little
bit of responsibility because people
look up to you because you're a couple
you should have but see that's the issue
there shouldn't be a couple's Channel
shout out you know
one I've I have been a fan since they
were back in Seattle
of Kev on stage and I always shot that
[__] out man and love Melissa
Mrs Kev on stage right and the thing
that I love most about them is that they
have been
the
they have been a couple that illustrates
love and specifically black love in the
most honest of ways
the most honest of ways because the
thing is is that if you are true if you
are in it it doesn't take a brain
scientist all it takes is having one
serious long-term relationship to know
how hard relationships can be and guess
what they had that relationship before
the fame before the fame none of this
stuff was out and the frame doesn't the
fame isn't gonna change the little
issues that they have and the thing that
you have to under the thing that people
don't understand especially when because
what was it the there was one couple
because I never I don't like couple
channels I don't like people that don't
tell the truth and when I say don't tell
the truth oh you don't like this type of
[__]
what's up everybody what's going on
Mitchell family here right now let me
tell you something you wake up at my
house like that you don't get [__]
stopped like this
my wrist crawled back just like this do
you know what waking up with a Mitchell
Family is it is walking out to see
Hunter on some back East phone call at
like 7 15 in the morning McKenna crying
for her ointment she can't even say
oatmeal but she demands it oatmeal every
day trying to make sure Devin gets up
downstairs and me trying not to talk to
any of them because I don't like to talk
to people when I first wake up in the
morning that is real life right but all
this like I hate I hate those let me not
say that that is not my type of
entertainment for people that make money
off of that you know kudos to you but
any person that has been in a long-term
relationship knows that no matter how
amazing y'all are doing there are still
things that this person does that annoy
you family channels are the worst thing
that happens they're the worst because
they are the worst because cause they
project this image and why people are
dumped at us and don't can't see past it
do you think I'm let me tell you
something I have one of the worst
pregnancies but best birthing experience
ever I had a great birthing story if
Hunter would have pulled out his phone
to Vlog you would have seen me detaching
the little heart monitors and punching
them in the face like I look a mess do
you think I want you to feel my birth
yeah yeah yeah look at the fact that
like there's times when you know because
I follow like
I felt like Jackie Aina I follow people
that I've been following for a long time
that could give me a service makeup hair
blah blah blah but so then because
they're you know technically like
lifestyle people and you get these other
ones I'm like do you think I really want
to watch you giving birth to twins yeah
nah I'm good
yeah
good and then you sit up there smiling
I've been through birth and I had an
amazing birthing experience but I was
like oh I can't can't wait to meet the
little like shut up man I'll tell you
this there was a a very popular Channel
that I used to follow as a family
channel and I don't know what channel
are you talking about no no it's a
different one
better talk to telekinesis yeah it was
it was a family channel about a Korean
dude and a and a black woman and they
were married and they had a couple they
had a bunch of kids right there's
there's two or three of them there's one
of them where there was some drama
behind it
do you know which one I'm talking about
are you gonna edit this out because I
don't want to like oh no I ain't gonna
[__] but if it's
but basically did the wife have like
super short hair yes and they just had
like they just kept having kids yes yes
yes
I know exactly what you're talking about
well I have questions for them so
there's like a couple of them were the
dope couples there was one couple and
I'm pretty sure you guys could fill in
the blanks and I'm Not Gonna Fill This
blank because I actually don't remember
their names
but I loved watching them at first right
because it was super interesting
watching this Korean Fabi do with this
with this black woman yes you know and
it was like the meshing of their
families like they would do videos like
like wash day and you see them doing all
79 kids hair and they uh you know they I
think they met each other through church
right of course that's how it is and
next thing you know that turns out there
in this hyper abusive [__]
relationship it was wild
what
it all for people it's like oh you want
to see culture and culture match with
each other I'm gonna make money off of
this [__] and they did like they even
had they were like teaching our kids
Korean blah blah blah
and then you come to find out that it is
trash and that is actually why they are
them and there's
there's a there is a Christian
couple
that I effing hate I often hate them and
I used to follow them but part of the
reason why I hate this one person is or
I hate the specific influencer is
because
she has this whole like I was out in the
world and I was dating Ballers and I was
giving myself up and then I met this
pastor who was rich and comes from a
lineage of Bishops right and I dedicated
myself in our first kiss was at the
altar and I'm vegan and I'm this and I'm
that I said girl you said vegan I
already gave up girl
you just started giving your [__] to
the church oh I'm about to get in
trouble what
but yeah you started you you closed your
legs temporarily because y'all's
engagement was nine months
okay
and then you started busting it open for
a pastor you just changed one dollar for
another exactly and you put on two women
that this is the way to go
but the thing is you just went from
tricking from tricking for these dudes
to tricking for the church and this is
y'all know I love Jesus you know David
you know I love Jesus look at her making
her case right okay I love Jesus I'm a
Believer through and through I will die
on a cross for the Lord but you're a hoe
for the church you went from you and
this is the probably the thing is she
was about to age out because she's our
age
so you about to age out with the with
the uh athletes and you just found
another way but then you go out here and
then you make women feel bad exactly
and look there are so many people who
will use like a wave to go ahead and
bolster themselves right but it's only
for very selfish reasons right and I got
super upset years ago when there was
this girl who online so you know me and
Tim did this video right and the ongoing
joke on the channel is that
everybody Tim's famous and I'm not right
so there was these two regular girls
you're famous to me yeah all right so
there's these two you know I thought I
actually love it when people ask you to
take pictures of them with them that's
hilarious you are my family so I don't
love it but then it is hilarious it's
hilarious and I love it too it's [__]
funny right and so the ongoing joke for
four or five years is that obviously I
make fun of the fans right because it's
based on ridiculous yeah
is on some ridiculous [__] that's
clearly not true so there was these two
girls who were just regular Asian girls
right and they were walking up Tim and
they were taking photos like man look at
these floozies talking to Tim and saying
that which episode you're talking about
and I actually laughed so this [__]
[__] I'll say it starts going on this
and this is during the metoo movement
and so she's she you know posts on my
page at me I am rolling my eyes at me
too but I'm not but I'm I'll explain
that so I don't get canceled she starts
saying like women are you gonna let this
man down talk another woman uh you know
when we go through some I was like hold
on do you know what this joke's about
this joke's about me it's less about you
girl and it's more about me I was like
it has nothing to do with you you're
clearly regular women people are
laughing because you guys are just
normal and I'm salty for no [__]
reason I'm making fun of myself you
stupid [__] idiot but of course she's
so [__] dumb that she's over here
mouthing off and then everybody started
ripping into her so she kept going in in
on it more then she got her dumb [__]
you know Captain Save A whole guy
friends to come message me
you could come get it at any [__]
time please don't play y'all please
don't play with David he's from he's
from Sacramento like if you want to come
get it you can get these [__] hands
beauty supply stores like please don't
mess with him like I will pray for you
out of love because I don't fight
anymore but listen do you not let the
right person try you yeah but at the end
of the day exactly I'm trying so it's
like and I said that's not through with
us yet and I talked to my mom about it
she goes you know what it's not worth it
I understand what your joke is but she
didn't want to be a part of the joke she
doesn't get the joke so just take it
down so I was like I was like you know
what my mom's right so I took it down
and we just kind of moved on from it
right and but I really disliked how she
took something that was supposed to be
positive for women and use it for her
selfish reasons and I'll check this [__]
out so so
Tim decides that he was gonna he
apologized to the girls right Tim's like
I don't want any problems or whatever
what not and then uh he was like look if
you guys ever want you know meals on me
because it was a food event anyways I
could buy you a meal and I apologize in
person whatever and so the other girl
who didn't cause a scene she didn't care
she understood the joke she thought it
was funny
the other girl
unfriended her other friend that was in
the video because she didn't get a
personal invite she's on her high horse
so she's already just an evil jackass in
general right and she was hating on her
friend she was like oh you're not with
me or whatever whatnot she un they're
not friends anymore you know what I'm
saying be glad girl so I'm gonna say
take this to the day that I die I was
not [__] wrong I just took the
[__] high road and guess what evil
will always show it [__] show itself and
that's what happened so she went off she
[__] went off on her friend saying
like oh how come I didn't get it in like
how come I didn't she was like no he
said that both of us but he messaged me
and so she unfriended her friend next
thing you know uh you know me I'm Petty
I did a little snooping I found out
you know Petty WAP is what I am one eye
let's go I [__]
I got the vocals for it
that you do you know I'm saying so
I go stooping on her page right this
girl over here [__] half naked
[__] deep throating bottles and [__]
I'm like okay so you're not even what
the [__] are you talking about but
that's why she was offended is because
you were
unbeknownst to you
addressing part of her I didn't even
know about it I mean because she just
looked like a regular averaging let me
tell you something my lovely genius fart
this podcast is brought to you by Factor
my friends factor is America's number
one ready to eat meal kit that can help
you fuel up fast was flavorful and
nutritious Brady emails delivered
straight to your freaking door you'll
save time eat well and stay on track
reaching your goals I got a bunch of
fact meals sent to me and I obliterated
every single one save me time super
delicious and now look at me I'm the
sexiest I've ever been looking for
calorie conscious options this summer
try delicious dietitian approved calorie
smart meals with a round or less than
550 calories per serving but know my
friends they did not did not take away
on the flavor because they are stupid
delicious we're talking about roasted
garlic filet mignon we're talking about
cajun spice sweet salmon so surf and
turf options my friends a whole bunch of
other stuff head to factormeals.com
if you can get 50 off your first box
that's code geniusbrain50 at
factormeals.com50 to get 50 off your
first bottles genius brain farts my
friends this podcast is brought to you
by Zach doc look you're trying to find a
cause for your symptoms right whether it
be an itchy throat itchy eye Itchy Butt
itchy nipple whatever it is and you
stumble down a Tick-Tock Rabbit Hole
full of questions advice from so-called
experts well they don't don't anything
there are better ways to get answers you
want and the care you deserve from
trusted professionals to not random
people on the internet doc dot helps you
find expert doctors and medical
professionals that specialize in the
care that you need and deliver the type
of experience you want stop getting
advice from who Haas and boo-boos my
friends get it from a professional that
knows what they're talking a about no
more Dr roulette or scouring the
internet for questionable reviews but
docdoc you have a trusted guide to
connect you to your favorite doctor you
haven't met yet millions of people use
docdocs free app to find and book a
doctor in the neighborhood who is
patient reviewed and fits their needs
and schedule just right zotalk is the
only free app that lets you find a book
doctor who are patient reviewed take
your insurance are available when you
need them and treat almost every
condition Under the Sun go to zocdoc.com
Jesus and download the ZocDoc app for
free then find and book a top rated
doctor today many are available within
24 hours that's
zocdoc.com genius
always tell on himself that's how people
get exposed because when people say like
oh I'll see your true colors they think
there's going to be some Grand reveal
it's like Noah sometimes the truth being
told is me unknowingly tapping into
something to you and then you go into
Super defense mode and this is what I
love about you too because like I
remember you know we I was going through
some type of [__] and we had a long
phone conversation with somebody else
who was a snaky ass [__] you know and I
just
I think like the the process that I was
going through was the idea of like I
actually was upset at myself because I
knew of this person's behavior and I
didn't bet on myself right I bet on when
other people said give this person a
chance they're not like what you and I
let this person in my [__] Circle you
did right and they I have to take
personal responsibility for that now on
that person's side they think I'm fake
because they're like oh you were super
nice to me and I'm like no no
I didn't bet on myself because you
showed your true color since the
beginning but through conversations of
people that I trusted I let other people
I let other people's Judgment of you
affect what I already knew exactly and
then when it came out I felt embarrassed
I was ashamed of myself I'm like you
knew better you knew what this person
did you knew how they behaved since day
one but you just had conversations with
somebody else hey can you help them out
they're not as bad as you think and I
said all right maybe they see something
that I don't and they came and they
[__] up my personal life did you know
what I mean oh
I remember but again it's like I told
you right is that I feel like that's
also where
some of the downfall of being a Believer
and being a Christian can
and I told you this then can actually
hinder us is because
as a Christian like your mindset or what
we've been taught is that you also you
always should assume the good so then
when you assume the bad and then it
seems like other people again let you
trust see the good then you ignore what
your gut or what your conscience is
telling you which in this case you know
it could be the holy ghost or maybe you
know like it could be right it could be
God being like uh that's not it but
because of the way that we're program
you fall into it so it's so again you
taking accountability is one thing but
it's a lesson learned that you bet on
yourself yeah and um you know that was a
real hard time for me because like I
listen I'll be I'll be 100 honest with
you there wasn't the [__] day that
went by that I don't want to see this
person and break their [__] legs and
till this day if I see them out in the
streets some [__] might happen facts
because some like
when people say God's not through with
me yet I I holy tap into that because
some people will only learn by my whole
fist being down your throat
and then you know what I mean like
there's some people that there's some
people that
in learning we have different modalities
I'm about to be counseled by all
teachers right you have visual Learners
you have kinesthetic Learners you have
auditory Learners well some people only
learn through physical violence
they got these knuckle Learners yeah you
sometimes
if there is certain P there are certain
people that just need to be punched in
the face one time
every now and then because the first
time you get punched in the face I bet
you that may be your last time and this
person has not been punched in their
face and that's why they keep doing the
things that they do and they're very
good at being manipulative and kind of
victimizing themselves where a lot of
people believe in their SOB stories
right and so for me I just always been
cordial and kind
um
for better than me
better than me by the grace of what
other people have said and for them you
know if they're listening to this which
they probably are because they always
probably are so just know that if Dave
doesn't see you first if I see you first
you don't get punched by some random
black girl that you don't know because
you messed around and tried the F up my
brother's life this is what it is and
this is the thing too
on site this is what the thing is too
and when we always say that you know
evil kind of reveals itself right it's
so it's so weird that Within These group
of friends how come everybody stayed
together but your group of friends
didn't
how come everybody went their their
other way how come you don't talk to
them anymore right how come the people
who said that they hated me at first
they went to you they came back and
they're like
I could kind of see what you're saying
and I'm like oh that's funny either way
you're still cut out too because I I
confided in you you try to use that
against me went to them and you found
out
and now you and I are not friends
anymore right because you knew me like
I'm always honest about my [__] facts
right I may not be the best person I'm
an [__] sometimes I'm scatterbrained
all that other stuff but if you are my
friend you're loyal I'm loyal as [__]
that's just what it is that's how I grew
up it's just what it is if you're a
periphery friend you don't count listen
I met Megan a few years back we've had a
couple of interactions but for some
reason we're [__] we're we're like
this we're tight we're tight I don't
know what the [__] it is you're in my
favorites after that conversation you
put me in my favorites I actually butt
dialed it accidentally because she was a
part of an m and then I hit her up but
it was like instant but I also feel like
I also feel like and this is a lesson
that I've had to learn that it's not
always longevity because I'm one of the
few people that my ultimate best friend
has been my best friend since we were
five in first grade
right so I'm always a person that
believes in longevity but as I become an
adult and like grown in adulthood I
realize that it's not always longevity
sometimes you need to let go of
longevity because you guys have outgrown
each other that's hard too
that's [__] hard I know I know it is
hard but what I have learned with even
friendships like us and another one like
I have a I have a whole
tights knit circle of friends that I
just met when I went to the school that
I currently work at right but I've
realized that it's not about the
longevity it's about the connection it's
about the energy it's about God
ordaining people together and it's and
we have so many people in common that is
not a surprise but the connection like
when I say brother like I mean brother
you know what I mean so it's not no we
haven't known each other for 20 years
but every time we break bread every time
we meet up every time we have a
conversation it is something that is
changing for my life or exactly what I
need and vice versa you know what I mean
so it's not it's not even about the it's
just about the mirror I feel like good
people
I feel like good always wins so I feel
like the good in you recognizes the good
in me and that's why we're able to be so
close and have such intimate real family
conversations is because it's the
goodness like there's no like I don't
have a guard up with you which I'm a
super guarded person I don't feel like I
have to hold anything back like I feel
like I can just
tell you what it is and I know that it's
gonna stay there and I know that the
advice or the words that you sow into me
are going to be good and that's what it
is you know and those that's a really
important thing too I feel like the
people that I connect with the most are
people who allow me to be who I am right
and I don't have to worry about these
things not the Persona like let you be
you and by the way too it doesn't mean
that you know occasionally I'm not going
to say something that's [__] up but
then I'll you know because I'm around a
good person I'll be able to kind of fix
those things autocorrect on my own
because I'm around a person that I
respect a lot you know creating strong
bonds is a really difficult thing for
young people nowadays and they always
ask how do you how did you meet Barton
Shield how did you guys connect guess
what it took time and we did connect we
sparked off over a long time but then
through time as well we continue to
learn and grow together right so Bart
and Geo are not perfect Joe is not
perfect I'm not perfect right and guess
what I'll even say this when I do dumb
things I guarantee you we're going to
talk [__] about each other amongst our
groups but the moment somebody else says
some [__] about Joe
you shut the [__] up those are my
friends I talked [__] about them but I
will also tell you to your face I think
that's something people confused with
loyalty right is that me being loyal to
you means that I want to see you win so
I want to see you win if you're doing
something that's wrong or that's
completely off base
I feel like you should rather me tell
you than everybody else tell you so I
can tell you a that was dumb as hell or
like crazy
like you need to back up but you know
because I love you is coming from a
place of love and wanted to and respect
and I want to see you win versus I'm
just finding a reason to tear you down
and I'll give you a great example about
that [__] trash made [__] made
[__] so this person that we were
talking about trash trash garbage hot
garbage if you don't know you're trash
and I know that you know because I know
I get you don't see this podcast
and just know the reason why we're not
saying your name is so that you don't
get the glory exactly but you know who
you are and you know that you're trash
and I guarantee you the way you did my
brother
I'll say this your compost and I won't
even use you for my tomatoes
breaking tomatoes and if you're not
using them for tomatoes you're
definitely not using them yeah exactly
for anything else like listen
so there was this thing too where we
started finding out through other people
um
that this person was this is before we
stopped being friends I feel like I'm
getting mad because I'm already back on
my lip they were talking [__] about us
about you know inside family [__] right
you know stuff that we're flawed human
beings right and then we correct each
other along the way but this person was
outwardly telling people outside of our
Circle about the mistakes that we've
made that we've fixed that we're doing
better on that we apologize for telling
other people this stuff and that's crazy
because I would never do that to
somebody that I was close to you you are
protected here you could say what you
want you can [__] up with whatever you
want in the circle and so these people
will come at us salty as [__] we don't
even know who the [__] closeness is
relative yeah and so I'll be talking
objective it's like what do you mean
what did you hear this from and of
course they're just gonna say it like oh
that's funny well let me tell oh are we
gonna tell secrets let's tell secrets
then right if that's what it is let's
tell some secrets that's right I was
like let me tell you some other [__] did
they tell you you bought this did they
tell you about that and their mind just
buy a man bam
and they were just like oh I didn't know
that I was like you know why you didn't
know that because it's none of your
business and you shouldn't have known
that because it's not my mission for you
to look at this person like they're bad
because they're flawed and they're going
to get better because they're within our
Circle but they never think they're
gonna get better because that's why they
did what they did they never gave us
that same Grace so it's like ah I see
that's what it is I I see okay now I
know that this was never like this and
it sucks because we spent a lot of time
with these people but once again travel
the intimate spaces everything dude grew
up with their kids and all this other
type of stuff so I'm like oh I see
loyalty is different for you
um I understand and it might sound funny
for people who are like well didn't you
didn't really like them anyways it
wasn't that it was just I always had
this feeling that something bad was
going to happen and that other people
just
ingratiate them into my life and so let
me tell you something and um no I'm not
there was no you had no choice but to
allow this person in and I say that
because everybody who you were in close
connection and close proximity Is in
doing life with was loving this person
and you didn't have a choice yeah and
the hard part about this too is like
people don't understand this concept
when I was talking to a friend about
this too is like well I hope their life
gets [__] up and I was like I actually
don't want the life to be [__] up but
because the reason why is because I want
their life to be the best because happy
people don't hurt people like this I
want them to be happy that's a that's a
place of growth it really is because the
other side is if I see you I'll break
your kneecaps but I'm I'm a complicated
human being so I want them to do well
because I want them to be happy because
they stop doing this to other people I
want them to be happy because they have
children I don't want their children to
be able to eat I want them to grow up
not knowing their parents are pieces of
[__] I want them to be [__] happy so
this cycle [__] ends because they
will continue to do this over and bad
people can't raise healthy healthy
children that's the sad part too but I
can only hope that they do grow up
healthy or maybe these kids recognize
that their parents aren't the heroes
that they thought they are right and
guess what they don't even [__] know
this too but their kids they're
wondering what happened between us right
and guess what with me because when you
let me this is the thing people forget
by the time your child reaches two or
three
those are some of the most pivotal years
in child development of their life
so if you have your children around a
certain group or a sad group of people
and they're the ages of two or three
toddlers
best believe that that is the part of
their life when their brain starts
developing memories where they start
developing connections where they start
and I'm and I see it firsthand with
McKenna because with Kenna it doesn't
take her being around somebody a long
time it takes her having a good time
with somebody and she will not forget so
their children are definitely wondering
where's Uncle David oh 100 and guess
what if I do and sometimes I have see
them and they message me because they're
older now do you think I'ma say bad
things about their parents nope never
you know why because that's that's not
has nothing to do with them I was like
you know what it's like I'm just busy
you know like oh we still talk here and
there like I hope your parents are doing
great you know they'll sometimes gripe
to me about them I was like you know
what you should still love your parents
like they're because it has nothing to
do with them but I know for a hundred
percent fact they don't do the same for
me this is petty though and I say this
as a as a teacher is that sometimes
especially when children reach a certain
age
it's okay to let them know that their
parents suck
right because you don't want to Gaslight
them and you want to show them so I have
a I have a specific student in mind when
I say this and with this student
they already know that their parents up
one of their parents is trash like
already knows this right and so for the
longest time
I was trying to get them to
change the way they looked at their
parents but then at a certain point I
had to be like
you know what
sometimes our parents show us the person
that we don't want to be
yeah and I had to say that because I was
thinking even of myself right like one
of the things that my mom never did was
she never talked poorly about my father
and what was interesting was everybody
else around was telling me the truth and
so what frustrate me when I would have
anger or disappointment towards him and
my mom would never acknowledge it like
and so finally he cared about your dad
that's your father that's your one and
only father and I'm like one and only
father I don't know man
this man up and cheated on you who you
thought she was married marrying some
preacher and was not only a cocaine
addict but was a whoremonger
my sister and I are 18 months apart and
there's a kid in between us Jesus Christ
right like there ain't nothing about
there ain't nothing about it and so wait
this is about to sound super messed up
but when he died
first of all you have the audacity to
die on my ultimate best friend's
birthday trash like that's just how you
want to ruin my life right but when he
died even when he left he [__] up my
life he left you were messing up my life
so when he died my my sister who so the
family Dynamics even just for like
perspective
I have my older brother who is
technically a half sibling he's my
Father's son but his father obviously
and then his mother were so messed up
that when my parents got married he
moved in with us and when my parents got
divorced he was still with us until he
went to college so he's all I know yeah
right he's my brother so you have my
brother then you have my sister my
brother is Junior just turned he's 51
and I'm 37 and I'm a teacher and can't
do math so he is 14 years older than me
yeah yeah
so the three of us right now we know
that they're for the king siblings
there's like 12. no lie but these are
the three that I know okay so we decided
okay we're gonna go to the funeral we're
gonna go to the service
and
my brothers in his right mind is like I
can't do it I don't want to do it I
can't do it
and so you know for me part of the guilt
that I felt was when I made a decision
to cut off my father that automatically
made Allison my little sister her
decision to cut off my father too
because my mom was like well if Megan's
cutting him off
I you have to cut them off too right so
I feel like I made a decision for it so
she really wanted to attend the funeral
so I was like I gotta go because you
know maybe he's changed maybe he's
different whatever okay
so we go to this funeral and talk about
um a little closer oh I have a complete
meltdown
because I'm hearing people get up and
talk about him as if he was the most
amazing father to the point one person
said oh that must have got under your
[__] skin David when I
I don't need I didn't even talk to you
about this because I literally tried to
erase this out of my mind but it's
appropriate
so one of the speakers I got up was like
you know I know Wayne had a bunch of I
know how Wayne had a lot of children
and you know I know he was a good father
just because
and I'm like
then then she went on to say that she
hasn't even met his children so why are
you why are you oh did you know why are
you in death saying this man was a good
father when you haven't met any of his
children
Emmy zip zero you know getting up to
here guys in his car club talk about
like oh you know he raised me when my
own father you know walked out on me he
raised me
it's
why weren't you raising your own
children
yeah why would you raise your own
children a new slash [__] the
reason why you thought he was your own
father because he could pick you up and
leave you whenever the [__]
because your own father walked out and
he can show up and choose to show up
when he wanted guess what he did Kiana
that is my best friend since I've been
in five
she had never had even seen a picture of
my father I've known her since I was
born 1985 we met in 1990.
and she had never even seen a picture of
this man that's crazy that's crazy
so I I walked out the funeral like I
couldn't thank God for one of my best
friends Michelle a
who she came and she joined me at the
funeral and when I walked out she walked
right out with me because I was like I
am going to get up here and I'm gonna
blow up this whole funeral like hi so
I'm one of the children that you never
met and it's too interesting so I was
like let me just walk out yeah yeah let
me just leave okay
but
that reminded me that it's important to
not Gaslight kids like some of your
parents are trash yeah yeah
and for you to know that you're not
crazy you need to hear that they're
trash because going to his funeral and
hearing people talk about the amazing
father and the amazing man that he was
when I knew that he was jealous of my
mom's dog and poisoned the dog
when I tell you he was trash he was
trash told my mom she was gonna be his
second wife or third wife and she was
number six
like how I love my mom but she my mom
like I'm like bruh you had all this your
mom was like what I was trying to ask
her like but and she even said she even
said my ganna told her that like I just
stopped telling you things because I
didn't want it to affect our
relationship because I knew it was gonna
make a difference I'm like I'm glad to
be here but girl you really avoided all
the reflex people were coming to the
wedding just to see
Wayne get married to somebody else like
they thought it was Amusement right so
I'm like
I grew up with my mom who my mom is
amazing she's an amazing mom she
sacrificed so much for my sister and I
like after her after the divorce she
gave her whole life to my sister and I
right which is part of the reason why
I'm a people pleaser because she
shouldn't have given her whole life to
my sister and I she shouldn't have
um but I grew up with her trying to
sugarcoat things about my father where I
actually needed to know the truth I
needed to know that he was trash
yeah because if he's trash then I'm not
missing out on anything then you're not
like battling with this internal idea of
like what the [__] like I see these bad
things everybody's saying great things
about them I don't know what's going on
I see what you're saying I think so you
got it so at a certain point you need to
tell the kids if the kids are seeing the
things that you see you could tell them
things like in a way yeah you could tell
them things in a way that says you know
and for me what I tell my students say
yeah your parent is trash but I say you
know
who's perfect the kids say nobody I say
sometimes you just have to understand
that humans are doing the best that they
can and it may not be enough for you
but this may be the best that they can
offer yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
just put it like that because you don't
want a gas like this until no they're
perfect they're great yeah see what
you're saying or ignore it right because
you know we hopefully
children are going to school and
becoming critical thinkers and becoming
critical thinkers means that you're also
becoming observant yeah and the more
that you went still right and wrong that
means that the more the stronger my my
moral compass is going to be so if I'm
looking at a person yes this person is
half of my genetic my genetic makeup
right but if I can see that they're
trash
I need somebody to let me know that I'm
not tripping let me ask you something
yeah how do you function as like a
people pleaser because I'm definitely
not that like how hard is that to
navigate because I've been learning to
kind of be more of a people pleaser to a
certain extent instead of you know
throwing gasoline and burning everybody
across my way
um you know it took me a time time to
think about that too it's like why it's
like
how come sometimes you don't take into
consideration of like how other people
feel which is probably one of my worst
qualities and I'm not saying that I'm
out here just roasting everybody right
but I definitely choose honesty as a
route first but sometimes my tact isn't
the best right I've gotten a lot better
since my wife she's she's helped me out
a lot it's like hey sometimes you feel a
certain way yeah it's honest but shut
the [__] up everything you know it's
like you didn't have to go and do that
just because it's honest doesn't mean
somebody is something on Instagram but
it's rain it like resonated with me
which is like
honesty doesn't have to be brutal
exactly and I've I've learned that a lot
and this all and you know I learned
where it came from music because the
people I grew up around that were really
close were just like that they were
brutal as [__] and I've absorbed that
you know there's a positive side to that
as well the if you do survive it is that
those people that were like that they're
still my friends till this day because
we are just always open and honest with
each other most people aren't like that
and I have to understand that I'm a
little bit of an outsider you know so
I've been able to navigate that but as
like a people pleaser like there has to
be [__] exhausting it is but so I
think for me one of the things that
attributed to being a people pleaser is
and I've realized it's in my family
lineage
so
this was super interesting was finding
out that finding out for my Ghana that
my grandparents my great-grandparents
were not interested in desegregation hmm
so they lived in they were from
um Waxahachie Texas
which in its own way was kind of like a
Black Wall Street so my uncle was mayor
like they had yeah but it was like a
town that was a town of hard-working
affluent black people
20 minutes on the suburbs of Dallas
Texas
and they were fine like even in
interview I had to interview My Gana for
a class in college and one of the things
I asked her was how did you deal with
prejudice and she said I didn't like we
just stayed where we knew we were
welcome
saw their green book and everything so
they truly were like we are good y'all
just leave us alone and we'll leave you
alone right
and so that's fascinating it's crazy no
it blew my mind and even in like
research
Brown versus Board of Education was not
about desegregating schools which is
this myth that they tell us it was about
providing Freedom schools or black
schools with the same level of money
that they were white schools
and that the Supreme Court was like you
know we just need to get rid of this so
it was
it was actually
this sounds crazy but in some older
black Americans mind specifically my
both of my grandparents are deceased
um but My Gana was born in 1921 just to
like put into or I'm sorry 1924 just to
put in like her age right
and so they weren't asking for
desegregation they were perfectly fine
going to hbcus they went to Prairie View
they just wanted to be left alone
and so when the desegregation of schools
opened up there's actually a book and I
cannot think of the name of the book but
it talks about this this black man who
went from being the principal of his own
school to then after these segregation
of schools become in the janitor
and talks about specifically so when
Brown Brown versus Board of Education
happened was 1954 they started
desegregating the schools my mom was
three
so because they knew how to text the
Texas school system was my whole family
literally
on my mom's side that whole family left
Texas and moved to California
because California schools were already
desegregated they had his heads up they
they were already doing so they were
already were like we're just gonna move
out here and my uncle was I called talk
about family trauma my uncle was already
in school so they sent him out here
first to live with my great-grandparents
my great-grandparents were able to like
close up shops they were retired and
moved out here first right
but my uncle being that my uncle
is so I'm telling all the family
business but being that my uncle had
recently found out that my grandfather
was not his biological father he thought
he was moved out here because they
didn't want him
so then he became an alcoholic like like
drug abuse like all these things
thinking oh they sent me away they
abandoned me right my mom and my aunt
never knew why they left Texas they
never knew and I only knew this because
for one of my black Studies classes I
had to interview my Ghana so I knew all
of this and when I tell you I just told
this to them like in 2021 they had no
idea my uncle didn't even know that my
aunt and my mom knew that my grandfather
wasn't his biological father
is crazy
right because they want to talk a
breakdown in communication it was but
also the thing I tell my mom and my Anna
my uncles I was like y'all were living
it so it's easy for ganna to recall it
to me because I'm asking her to tell me
about different things in her life how
do we get to California y'all never
asked because y'all lived it so
so much of my family being in California
is hinged on the fact of schools were
becoming desegregated and when they
moved here
and my grandparents mine they were like
well we gotta fit in so what does
fitting in like look like assimilating
the whiteness
so part of being a people pleaser was to
be successful my my grandpa ended up
being a postmaster
in LA
um my
you know my grandparents owned this
outside of him working for the U.S
Postal Service he also owned a
successful
mechanic shop so they were homeowners
they were business owners and they
thought that the reason why they were
those things was because they
assimilated to whiteness so that was
also part of the people pleasing
then
growing up in a very
Christian Pentecostal household that
also comes with this ideology of
obedience
right and so when I say like being a
people pleaser
it was like instilled in me like I
literally watched my mom and my Gana and
my aunts and my uncles living out
don't let your brother how to have an
ought against you right like that was a
scripture they lived by like if you do
something and even if you're not trying
to make it offensive but offend somebody
you got to apologize so I grew up this
way then I grew up feeling you know
because of my parents divorce feeling
like
well if I'm easy to love meaning I
always show up for you and I don't ask
much for you in return then you won't
leave me oh [__] yeah yeah so I spent
like a solid
34 years operating that way so it's
really been in the last three years that
I felt like I've been like you know what
I want to apologize and and to be honest
a lot of that was with
was the
Awakening that came after the murder of
George Floyd because and and it should
have happened earlier than that right
because even with with Hunter my husband
college educated he works for PWC he
goes to a Clipper game with
um with one of the partners and
directors when he worked for PWC he's in
a suit and everything and because he's
drinking at the game he decides he wants
to take the train back to Long Beach
meeting him at the Long Beach station
he doesn't show up I'm like what is
happening calling our friends I'm
calling everybody turns out he got
arrested on the train
and it's like how does a black man who's
college educated works for a big three
company in a suit in a suit get arrested
on the train
and so then that even humanized it to
where oh it doesn't matter what you wear
you just have to you know Kanye said
even if you if even if you want a Benz
you still a [__] in a coop and I heard
that line but I didn't understand that
line and it wasn't until 30 I would say
33 34 where I was like
regardless of how I show up I cannot
change the color of my skin and I won't
so even if I talk like this and my
name's Megan Ashley King Mitchell and
you don't know what I am it doesn't
matter so then why am I going to
assimilate why am I going to co-switch
so then I just stopped so I've been
having to unlearn
things that were ingrained inside of me
even before I was born I mean there's a
lot of people who are kind of learning
that who are you know if if people who
have listened to this podcast you will
hear me say two different things and
these are two very distinct things I say
black American and African-American
black American is not African-American
it is not and it's you know people yes I
love you because you understand the
Nuance people used to get on my case
about that it's like you're supposed to
say African no no no [__] there are
two different things two different
cultures two different identities two
different experiences there are people
from Africa who know their lineage who
came here on purpose right there are
people who are black and white by choice
there are people who are black Americans
who grew up here because they came here
as property and chattel there's very
different things and people find that
it's totally different and that's why I
miss teaching fifth grade it's because I
could explain to my students like
explain to my students if you ask Toby
chuku she's not going to be able to tell
you the ramifications of of being a
descendant of enslaved people because
his parents willingly came over here
about 25 years ago yeah and like this is
not on some [__] it's just like some
facts right it's how people feel and uh
Juneteenth doesn't mean anything to my
friends who are nigerian-american or
Senegalese American they have their own
Ghanaian American because they have
their own language they they have their
own culture they have their own language
they can go back to their country of
origin because again people Africa is a
continent not a country so they can go
to their country in Africa and see their
family members yeah and so you know
people didn't really understand that and
you know people were trying to correct
me and I'm like am I getting something
wrong it's only just but once again it's
like I I grew up around black culture
and then you know when you grew up one
of your best friends is African-American
and so you understand the Nuance you
understand the difference exactly and
one of the hardest parts in my my friend
amono told me about this where she goes
you know in her family too they never
understood and they they actually had
the the I didn't know this but she said
they African people have the Mind state
of an immigrant right so if anything
else is very similar to Asian immigrants
facts right so this is total facts they
don't relate to the black Americans so
one of the hardest parts for a lot of uh
African immigrants who come here they
also have like this judgmental uh
outlook on black Americans right a
thousand percent and they go well we're
not them so people are going to know the
difference and the Heart pill for them
to support was that they don't give a
[__] they don't they just see that melon
in your skin and they go you're black
automatically I mean even when I look
within my own with my in-laws
one of the one of the biggest takeaways
I learned from my in-laws is that even
though they're Panamanian they're black
so they always identify as
afro-panamanian because if you see if
you see my husband's Abuelita you're
gonna think she's just a black granny
until you open up her mouth and you're
like wait why do you have a Spanish
accent because she was born and raised
in Panama that's crazy like speak
Spanish Spanish was her first language
yeah yeah yeah
and so
they understand it and I think the
reason why afro-panamanians under are
afro-latinas and afro-latinos or
afro-latinx whatever you want to
identify as understand it is because
even in their country they're still
viewed as the minority they're still
viewed as the as the lows on the tone
Pole right but when you come in from
Africa once you leave morocc once you
leave African countries that were
colonized
that's a key word right because we
forget that Egypt and Morocco are
African countries they were just
colonized which is why they don't look
like the rest of Africa right they are
in towns where everybody like if you go
to Lagos Nigeria
it was one of the one of the most
Awakening experiences for me and I feel
like that was kind of kismet that that
was the first cut the first African
country that I visited in the city that
I visited in Lagos was because I was
like oh my gosh
everybody's black yeah it's trippy isn't
it it is crazy that's how I felt when I
went to Korea I believe it and I
remember I said this phrase and I was
like I was like everybody needs to go
back from where they came from I was
like hold on a second not like that but
what I meant was like you go back and
you feel this like oh
these kind of belong it's weird it's
trippy as [__] you know what I mean
um and it's kind of comforting it is
that's this is why I my biggest I don't
have many regrets in life but one of my
biggest and it's actually my mama's
regret which she also regrets is not
letting me go to HBCU because all of my
friends that attended at HBCU you cannot
tell them nothing and even if we put it
at this like Diddy
you cannot tell Diddy that he did he
forever remains relevant Because he
believes he should be relevant product
of Howard University there is something
about being in spaces that are occupied
by people that look like you that are
excelling yeah
it's empowering it's it's empowering
yeah it reminds you that you are not a
blip on somebody's totem poor that
you're not an afterthought or that you
shouldn't be grateful that you deserve
to be here or you just have to like
prove yourself all the time right and um
you know what was that one movie it was
was this a Jordan Peele movie but
basically there was a line where he was
like
why do black people always have to be
excellent you know what I mean but that
is the fact it's like how come we always
have to prove ourselves to be up here
just so we could be right here yeah and
um you know I like that is that is facts
though is that being black and being
excellent is exhausting yeah because you
always have to be on your p's and q's
always because you're trying to offset
you know the the negative stereotypes
that you see on social media like we're
not saying or even the implicit bias
that people have grown up with yeah and
like we're not saying too like look
you're going to be able to cherry pick
out of all the pieces of [__] on Twitter
on YouTube that are black Americans
right but we could do that with anybody
right you could literally do that with
anybody and sometimes when people hear
you know you speak the way that you do
right or any other they imagine they
automatically put you into this box of
what your intelligence is right but it's
like sometimes you just don't know
people just speak a certain way
you haven't had a conversation with this
person you don't know anything about
this person and whatever your experience
was you got to talk to a person to get
to really know them and you know the
hardest part about that for a lot of
people when they
you know I say it too like America is
definitely it's the Hot Topic like race
obsession is really big here right well
that's because the whole country and
constructs of our government of our
hierarchy of our social classes are
built on Race yeah and like the hard
part is for people who live outside of
this country
um that they don't understand is that
how come all Americans talk about race
and they do laugh at us about this a lot
and I get it they should because it's
ridiculous yeah and then there's the
other side of it too it's like so for
example there was a video of a of a
young there's two uh uh British black uh
uh black British girls they were talking
about making fun of American people
right there's like I don't know why
don't you get like
you know I don't understand black
American boys or girls because they
don't
you guys don't know where you [__]
came from and it was like
yeah because they were slaves we were
enslaved what the [__] are you talking
but she didn't understand it she said
they don't but that's the thing is that
the Black American Experience
is one that is truly unique it's Unique
to only this country and only blacks in
this country and here's a Trippy part
about it too she kept on you know
dogging this guy saying like no
seriously tell me she goes I'm Nigerian
I know where I'm from where are you from
he goes he's not even answering he
doesn't want to dignify he goes he just
looks at the camera like somebody want
to explain to this girl what what's
going on here but you wanna know why
it's because in other countries they
don't like
America is the only country where you
will have to learn about one what should
be one of the
most horrendous parts of our history
which is slavery like in Germany they
don't teach about the Holocaust why
because it is a blemish on their history
yeah but in America this is the only
country where you are going to not only
glorify people that were slave owners
but then teach people about slavery
and think that's okay yeah and you know
whenever I go online people always have
something to say about a culture that
they don't really know about it they
never really partook in right and look
you could talk about stats and
everything else and then people could
start bringing in their facts about why
the things are the way that they are at
the end of the day the only thing I ask
is like
if I if I went in through your phone
right and I saw pictures of your friends
how many of them are black
and if you don't have those people from
a community
that you have never spoken to
how do you really [__] know you can
only tell by the stuff that you hear
from people right because I could do the
same to you I could do the same to you I
could cherry pick all these like shitty
other [__] things that I've seen like
why people do Asian people do Mexican or
whatever right but the one thing that
kind of stays true to me
um that I've seen a lot is that even
though that you have people in your
community who have just as bad qualities
they never get highlighted like they do
in the black community
and that's how I feel right and that's
what I see a lot but that is a fact like
I think the thing is that it's not just
the way that you feel it is a fact it is
a fact like to be
to be black and successful in America is
exhausting
and I'm even coming from a place of
privilege I'm coming from a place of
socioeconomic privilege where
I've been I've been permitted and I say
permitted because these weren't
necessarily spaces that were designed
for me but that I've been able to
infiltrate these spaces because of
privilege you know like I'm not a first
generation college graduate my mom what
my mom had her master's degree before I
was even born yeah you know what I'm
saying so of course I'm gonna go to the
best schools and even teaching the
Cerritos one of the things that I used
to lead by because I would know I'm like
okay I'm teaching at this school
and this school is
a high performing school and I'm a black
teacher so what is the best way to win
over parents oh I tell you I'm a Whitney
graduate
immediately yeah and you have enough
friends to group in Cerritos and went to
Whitney to know what that means so the
moment that parents find out that I'm a
Whitney graduate I am the queen of their
Castle yeah
right like that already shows you how
intelligent I am that shows you my
experience the fact that I went there
from Seventh through 12th grade I
graduated from there like I got a full
ride to college like that eliminates so
many questions and I use that absolutely
because
that is going to that is going to lessen
the chances of you questioning things
that I decisions that I make or grades
that I give your student because I'm
black because the fact that I've
graduated from Whitney is going to
triumph over the fact that I'm black so
any doubts that you had for me
any doubts that you had against me
the fact that I said I Whitney Whitney
at high school yeah like that changes
everything you know what's really hard
too like I see from a lot of young kids
uh especially young black kids who don't
They Don't Really perpetuate the popular
stereotype that people see of of a young
black American right like they don't
have they don't they don't listen to
hip-hop slang whatever whatnot right and
sometimes people in the black community
they [__] on these kids like you're not
black it's like that was me it was hard
you know it's like how come this you
talk like a white girl and my name was
Megan before was popular yeah you know
my girl like going to going to church in
the going to church off of 79th in
Vermont
and talk in the way that I talk is oh
this is this is after having a plethora
of black friends and going through Cal
State Long Beach and walking through a
little Crenshaw that I talk like this
now yeah but back in the day it was like
hi and I was a cheerleader oh my gosh
yeah hi
hi David like I was always ugh Why are
you talking like a white girl or you
think you better than a white girl and
then don't don't let the fact that I'm
gonna come dripped out and I dripped
like I was coming in the real stuff like
I was I wasn't head to toe like thank
thank God my mom was college educated
because all the trends I had yeah yeah
yeah yeah the designer bags was not like
you know this whole premise of soft life
I was like I was raised in a soft life
yeah that made it worse yeah that's why
I had to learn how to fight yeah
because people always had some [__]
because I was at church conventions with
people when people wanted to say
something slick yeah Church convention
at a church convention I was laying
hands not the way that the pastors were
talking about this is what I'm talking
about like it's so hard sometimes like
you know and I do want people to
understand too not just what the black
community Asian Community just or your
community whatever it is even with my
folks it's there's no it's not a
monolith everybody's different there's
different [__] flavors and you just
gotta let people exist right so when you
see somebody who's Asian that speaks a
certain way they they talk a certain way
let them exist they don't exist in the
way that you did but they do exist and
it's still a part of your community
whether you like it or not like I saw
this one kid on Tick Tock and I really
felt for the kid because he's just like
he just wants some more wine oh hell
yeah this [__]
ah
wine break are you making me kill the
bottle
you have any other equally as much but
you you have in the other half so like I
I was watching this kid on Tick Tock and
he was just like he was a preppy kid
right
and he's like you know what I'm so sick
and tired of other [__] black kids
coming up to me making fun of me tell me
I'm not black enough that I'm not down
with anything he goes why the [__]
should I be ashamed that my parents are
college educated they work [__] hard
and I had the things that I [__] have
no I'm not gonna talk like you no I'm
not going to do things like you but it
doesn't change the fact that I'm a
[__] black man I'm black yeah so
don't take that [__] away from me you
know because I think so much and which
which this is what I love about our
generation is that we are redefining the
black experience
because I feel like for you know I'm I'm
definitely like I try to be unbiased
with so many things but when it comes to
generation I'm biased AF yeah Boomers
mess it up for everybody right we have a
concessions like we could all agree
about that [__] my mom my aunts they are
boomers
it's their sense of entitlement is like
no other right but the thing about black
Boomers was black Boomers were taught
that to be successful you had to
assimilate to whiteness so that's where
the idea of code switching came up Gen X
y'all messed up a lot too because y'all
are drug addicts yeah okay
10x y'all are wild y'all want this is
what it is is how I see it is that they
are wild like some of you younger people
you want everything the world has to
offer oh that you can see oh Jen's but
you want nothing to work for you want
nothing to work for that's gen Z we
don't get on them too yeah so like we
all have our problems you know what I'm
saying and that's the hardest part for
me it's like you keep seeing here but
you're not seeing the rest everything
here you know next is the party
generation so they lack efficiency and
they want everything to be a tournament
a party so they were just like okay well
I mean this is a house party situation
like they were like we want to turn up
and then okay we'll go to college to
become smart
Our Generation which technically were
zinnios because we're in between Gen X
and Millennials we had it the hardest
and part of the reason why we had it the
hardest was because we had to endure War
we had to bridge the gap between digital
Natives and non-digital and digital
immigrants
right we also were raised by Boomers or
or older gen xers which they had on Hill
trauma
but what we're trying to do now through
healing is we are trying to show up in
spaces authentically ourselves and show
that even me being my most authentic
self is excellent yeah
then we have Millennials who were the
beginning of participation ribbons and
then we have gen Z which is the kings
and queens of participation ribbons and
that's why they're so messed up is
because they feel like they should get
the accolades that's who I'm currently
teaching now is Gen Z whereas like well
we all get an award or why did you give
me this grade and I easily tell my kids
I said you look at the rubric and see
why you earned this grade yeah I don't
give grades y'all earn them right and so
for us
I'm hoping that one of the things that
we can teach our kids is how to
authentically show up
in every space because it even took me a
long time as a teacher like until the
2020 2020 one school year
I was not authentically showing up as
myself when it was summer I would get
braced but the moment school started I
would press my hair or get my hair flat
ironed when it came to wearing clothes
and things to school like I was going to
look what I felt like was a part of a
teacher versus now you're gonna get the
change you're gonna get all nine
earrings you don't get the nails you
gonna get the braids 24 7 because I
can't do mine and McKenna's hair and you
gonna get the JS and you also gonna get
the best education you ever could get
sitting right in my classroom with me
looking how I am 100 and I'm I'm
unapologetically showing up this way and
what I'm grateful for and this sounds
crazy but
my principle is a white man who gets it
and it's sad that I have to say that he
gets it because in in some ways he
allows me to show up authentically as
myself because that's how he wants me to
be because if he didn't I wouldn't be
able to
see this is the hard part too it's like
when
I wonder if people resonate with this is
if if if no if you are out there and
you've ever asked this question and
you've had this very awkward
conversation
you'll see this happen where somebody
will like I've had this conversation
before this is a very civil conversation
where they kind of Express their
feelings of like yeah I want you know
people around my kids or people that I'm
around not to be ghetto and I was like
all right cool what's what's ghetto to
you right and you know they want to say
what they want to say but they're kind
of boils down to Blackness I was like
listen just say what you want to say I'm
not mad like I just want to know I just
want a conversation right they're like
well sometimes you like you get hella
good I'll say what's ghetto and they're
like well you get I was like well I'll
just explain this to you right
what's bad about it
what what is so bad about it
explain to me let's say I'm not cursing
I'm not saying inappropriate things
nothing sexual or whatever whatnot but
you hear me speak with a certain way
that I do sometimes what is so bad about
it aside from the fact that I speak
different than you what is so bad what
am I preaching what am I saying what am
I teaching what is so bad
and you know the dude was like
man [__] I don't know it's just like I
think I just grew up knowing that that
right there is it's what low level
people do I was like yeah and that's
honest to you and that's the problem I
was like but here's the thing though
I'll be honest with you I'm smarter than
you [__] yeah we're laughing we're
friends yeah I mean it's like no but
it's just it's the truth like you you
know like big facts like look you know
you you consciously say you look up to
me right but then you're judging the way
that I speak it sounds a little weird to
me right sounds it sounds very weird but
I'm not judging the way you speak I
think that's just you right because you
and I grew up differently like you would
come from a humanizing place yeah and
like even for me now too like the
hardest part is that people will always
see it like I do constantly code switch
that's the part of my generation it's
always going to happen you know
um I I it just happens I don't even know
when the [__] it happens it just is what
it is right it just it's be it's because
it's something that's ingraining us yeah
and I've been working I've been working
really hard to to try and not co-switch
but I'm also like okay Meg you can't use
the n-word everywhere yeah right and I'm
I you know what say what you want to say
but I'm a firm believer in double
standards so yes I'm allowed to say the
n-word because I'm fully black you know
what's so funny don't try this at Home
Folks if you're not like just because
you have friends like that you're not
equipped to say it but I think it's also
hard though is that when we talked you
know earlier when we talk about advocacy
is being in spaces where The Gatekeepers
are white and knowing that I that I'm
smarter than you yeah it's like I am
more qualified to be here than you
especially being an elementary teacher
being a being an elementary teacher is
interesting because we are some of the
most qualified teachers out there and we
get the we get the bottom of the barrel
from our districts
meaning
secondary teachers and I must and I can
say this because I have multiple
credentials so I'm coming from a place
of I can teach I can teach from T from K
I can't teach TK I can teach K all the
way to 12th grade so with elementary
teachers we oftentimes get disrespected
because we're nurturing but what they
also remember forget to
um remember is that while we're
nurturing we're also equipped to teach
all the subjects so for in California
7th through 12th grade you need a single
subject credential
single subject means you take some C
sets in a specific subject one subject
and then you're allowed to teach 7th
through 12th grade
Elementary we have to be experts of
everything so we have to take a c set in
math
Ela
History Science PE and Fine Arts that's
six
we have to be subject matter subject
matter experts in six subjects then on
top of that which
secondary teachers don't have to take is
we have to take the Rica and what the
Rika does is the Rica tells me or tells
you that I am able to teach children how
to read
by the time you get to Middle School
sixth grade actually the assumptions
that you already know how to read so
that's why kids when they struggle in
high school and Junior High School they
don't get any help they just continue to
fall further behind because those
teachers not saying y'all don't work
hard but y'all got the same credentials
that we have y'all they're not qualified
to so you have
literally the Rika I can't even hey Siri
what does Rika stand for
oh shoot I gotta unlock
Siri
what does Rika stand for it's like
reading I'ma look it up
but you have English teachers or yeah
you look it up what does Rika stand for
you have English teachers who cannot
teach kids how to read because the
assumption is by the time they get to
them they already know how to read well
if you look at California test scores
you already know that that's not the
truth [__] Rico came a racketeer no
I'm not racketeering
Google you know what to look at reading
instruction competent assessment
all elementary teachers have that
reading instructional competent
assessment
other teachers don't have this but they
look down on Elementary School teachers
and the thing is is that we are the
foundation
you can't go to college unless you
graduate Elementary School you can't go
to Middle School unless you promote from
elementary school if we were to pour in
more resources and support for
elementary school teachers we would have
a lot less intervention in secondary
school we you would have a lot less
emotional trauma in secondary school you
will have a lot less cultural bias if we
switch ethnic studies there's now an
ethnic studies initiative in California
for high school students
by the time you get to high school
you've already gone through eight or
nine years of racism yeah yeah yeah yeah
whereas if you started teaching kids in
TK
cultural appreciation uh responsive or
culturally responsive pedagogy by the
time they get to sixth grade they be
proficient at it and so because of that
for me as a black teacher I'm like I'm a
black sixth grade teacher in elementary
school which most Elementary's are
you know
um TK through fifth my district is still
sixth grade yeah so I'm one of the few
chances that you will have as a black
student to see a person in power that is
black that is wholly black
authentically black I make no apologies
for being black I have black art in my
classroom I talk about my experience as
a black woman I invite my students to
talk about their experiences as people
or non-people of color
and so my hope is by the time you in
sixth grade
you will have a lens into all these
different cultures that even if you get
to Middle School
you'll still have the understanding from
sixth grade and I think that's really
important specifically in America right
because America is so integrated with so
many different cultures it might not be
the same in other people where like
there are more homogeneous societies so
it's not going to come up but when
you're in California you are going to it
is really preparing you to live in this
state specifically or maybe even in this
country because I know California is
super even like we pay the California
luxury tax of convenience but California
is still super segregated oh yeah
100 and I think like before other people
when they hear this they go well isn't
that a little personal I was like I
actually don't think teaching kids how
to deal with different cultures is
personal because it's just a part of
your everyday in this country it is what
is going to be expected yeah so cultural
proficiency it'll help them out yeah a
cultural proficiency is a bonus yeah and
part of the reason why I was originally
saying that was because I was like
elementary teachers are so looked down
upon yet we are we spend the most time
with students
when I taught Middle School I taught
block schedule and I taught um a regular
schedule so I was either with you for 90
minutes or I was with you for 55 minutes
elementary teacher all 180 days are
spent with me yeah
even if I have a sub you still come back
to me
so I have a lot of influence on your
life and people you know people look
down on that it's it's interesting like
this is kind of not really connected but
I definitely have some people come at me
because you know they never ever listen
to everything that I'm saying and they
don't allow me to Oh They'll explain my
thoughts or this yeah so like I said
this and it hit a button and people
didn't get it I still left it on the
podcast I don't give a [__] was like I I
thought that
the idea that we have to teach black
history in this country from an outside
perspective is dumb because black
history is just American history so just
teach in a part of American History you
don't have to call it black history you
don't it is American history but I think
that but that is so American in itself
that unless you are a white American
your history is other yeah Asian
American history I'm like lit if we
people get people don't get offended but
I say this all the time America has a
historic issue of immigration problems
and the immigration problem started in
the 15 and the 1600s
why because if you are white in America
you are an immigrant yeah and they
forget that
y'all have convenient revisionist
history yeah yeah yeah yeah America was
built on the idea of immigration so the
fact that you are trying to Target
specific cultural groups and not allow
them into a country your forefathers
your the framers were immigrants
you know the trippy thing too is like
the question of why do we have to go
ahead and teach black history no you're
asking the wrong question you're asking
how come I have to teach this part of my
history of my history I'm an American
this is a part of your history every
time you go into the White House you're
looking at black history yeah it's not
every time you stop at a stoplight
you're looking at black history but
let's also not forget the fact that it
even in California we have a revisionist
history when it comes to a lot of next
Americans and Asian Americans they built
California yeah I mean it's just built
like I always wonder too what's the
problem like why are you so against it
and I think what they think too is that
there's like a specific agenda in terms
of oh you guys just want to go ahead and
up your own culture it's like no I'm
just telling you just tell it like how
it is and it's not a problem just tell
it like how it is like the idea like
slavery is such a big like I said this
is from somebody who is an immigrant
Asian person and it just weird because I
do see this a lot in Asian countries too
well they'll get rid of certain
tragedies like as if it never happened
like it doesn't exist it happens we're
[__] American I'm proud to be a
[__] American so you should we should
have the freedom to go ahead and talk
about the things that happen here and
learn from it you know what I'm James
Baldwin he literally said the reason why
I'm critical America is because I love
her so much a hundred percent and so I
think because we grew up in California
they do teach you know black history as
a part of our American history stuff and
it's just it's always been a little odd
for me where I'm like why is this called
Black History not just American history
and why is it only time in February yeah
it's like it's like it's just it's a
huge part of this country it's a huge
part of how this country was built is a
huge part of everything right and it's
okay to talk about it it's the idea that
we think that we could pull this part
out of our history books because we just
don't want to talk about it even though
it is a very integral part of this
country's story and that's just how I
see it but then you know when I said
this they're like you want to get rid of
black history he's like no you dumb [__]
[__] that's not what I'm saying I'm
saying that it needs to not be a
separate history yeah it is it shouldn't
be a separate class it shouldn't be like
it's a part of the curriculum it's the
part of the curriculum but it should be
ingrained in it in a way that doesn't
make it othered
the way that American
slavery is presented is presented as a
blip in American history but you cannot
teach American history without talking
about the fact that this country was
built on the backs of indigenous and
enslaved Africans yeah you cannot
and I think that's what I think I just
don't want to say the problem like
what's the problem here because then you
have to admit it like it's history it
happened it's history teach history but
because then you have to admit that it
was wrong because that's the issue that
we have right is that
the Selma movie right
everybody was up in arms because it
showed that Martin Luther King was
a cheater okay
it's a fact
that doesn't negate for the fact that he
was advocating for civil rights that
doesn't negate the fact that he was
fighting and that he did good things but
we forget that our
pioneers and people that we look up to
can be flawed 100 we try to make our
people
we try to make our people
Heroes and martyrs like Olympians almost
in a way right
George Washington okay he was a great
Soldier but you know what else he owned
slaves and he was kind of a trash person
Abraham Lincoln
don't tell me he freed the slaves he
didn't because because
critical thinking would tell me if the
South had already succeeded in the union
writing the Emancipation Proclamation
for a territory that said they weren't a
part of the United States that would
literally be me writing to China and
saying y'all are a democratic country I
don't have any control over that right
and then also the fact that even Abraham
Lincoln thought there should be limits
he blatantly wrote in a letter that he
did not believe that black men should
have the same rights as white men and
that's okay to tell the truth it just
happened it just happened but people
have a problem remember when 12 Years a
Slave came out how many people were mad
I'm like this is a Slavery movie what
the the [__] are you talking about but
it was also facts that people didn't
realize that that slave owners in the
South would send U.S Marshals you want
to know how the marshals began that's
how they began they were slave Hunters
but then they were also kidnapped freed
blacks and dragged them to the South
yeah that's not like that's not a story
that's fact and guess what if we know
the facts always tell my kids I'm going
to tell you the truth in hopes that you
learn from the truth and don't repeat it
yeah yeah
the reason why America is in the racial
endemic that we are now is because
people aren't telling the truth yeah
they're getting shocked by everything
they're getting shocked I can't believe
this I can't believe that like look you
look into any country's history you're
gonna find you're gonna find something
even African history is flawed of course
there's a lot of stuff out there you
know what I mean and like I said to you
the truth shouldn't have to hurt you in
the way that it does but you should
acknowledge it you know
um and learn from it yeah it just is
what it is like when I hear people with
Christianity it's flawed like history is
the Bible is one of the greatest
history books because it
unapologetically shows
bald people
there's only one person in the Bible
that was perfect and that was Jesus
himself
and we still saw him get angry
we still saw him not like being about
that life right
but I'm like we try to sugarcoat even
with my father right like you're trying
to sugarcoat history
you can still pay which this he I'll see
I'm about to say that word he was about
he did not deserve to be respected I I
will I don't care if he gave me half my
DNA that's all he did he doesn't deserve
to be respected but even if he wanted to
honor him let's say you had a positive
experience with him you could talk about
that positive experience and him being a
trash father can still be true yeah
100 but we grew we are in a society
we're in a country that doesn't believe
that the same way that we can demonize
Hitler
but you still want to praise Andrew
Jackson is mind-blowing
is mind-blowing to me
right because in America we believe that
our heroes can't have flaws one of my
this is gonna seem off topic but it's
very relevant right
part of the beef that the Avengers have
with Captain America was that he never
admitted where he came from yeah and he
never admitted his flaws it wasn't until
in game where you saw him as a flawed
person
actually I'll solo you out it wasn't
until
um Captain America Winter Soldier where
you saw him sticking up for his friend
which was the unpopular thing to do that
you really saw him be flawed right and
it's like
while I am a die-hard MCU Marvel comic
fan not just the movies been like this
my whole life
I thought that was so telling because I
couldn't stand Captain America until
that movie because you have he you have
to be humanized you have to be flawed
yeah The Human Experience
I connect more with people that are
flawed and that say Jesus ain't through
with me yet I'm not perfect yeah I'm not
even trying to pretend like I'm perfect
I'm gonna mess up I'm gonna make
mistakes but I still I'm sorry plant but
I'm still gonna do good where I can yeah
yeah yeah that's what it that's what it
means to be human a lot of young people
need to know that too because I I feel
like the
when you're younger and this is like me
included we we all become absolutist
everything is an absolutely no it's it's
black or white there is no gray it's the
craziest thing especially when you
graduate college yeah oh kids then you
know everything hey let me tell you
something I know there's people in
college who are listening to this let me
tell you guys this right now you are the
future but you're the dumbest [__]
person on Earth right now because all of
you thinking absolutes everything is
absolutes your love lives are absolutes
how you think your morals uh everything
is absolute and the world doesn't really
work that way how many worst breakups
I've had in my life or life-changing
classes I've taken in my life
oh my God I'll never be the same oh my
goodness this is the worst thing ever my
college ex-boyfriend
I was like oh my gosh he told me he
literally he told me that I didn't have
the qualities that I wanted in a wife
that almost broke me
and I'm so happy for him but of course I
don't have the quality but my thing is
it's like in hindsight that almost broke
me bruh you didn't want to marry
don't even like [__]
well it's you know that's so such a
perfect example of what it is to be in
college speaking like you know so much
about everything when you don't know
[__] you don't know what it's like to be
the perfect wife that's funny you don't
like [__] the [__] would you know you
know what I'm saying how would you know
but at that time that shook me and I
didn't want to think is that I didn't
want to be with him
like I was a I wasn't my true self with
him but because everybody people
pleasing everybody around me thought we
were gonna get married I was going to
marry this man that doesn't even like my
vagina did you ever feel that he could
have been gay while you guys were
together it's like however when we were
together no when we were together no but
we also you know he was a youth Minister
we were super in the church and that was
gonna be hard to sniff out there it was
gonna be hard to sniff out but also for
me though I was not my true self with
him yeah yeah he liked
I do think that he was interested in me
that I think part of his interest in me
was because that's what he was taught to
be interested in
you know I was in college I was smart I
came from a good family at church I
dressed well he didn't see me slumbing
around Cal State Long Beach and Daisy
Dukes that had Beach across the booty
and a sweatshirt you know he didn't know
Megan that liked to drink Bacardi 51 or
151 and layout and and lot 20 with my
friends passed out you know he didn't
like Megan that was p-popping on a
handstand but on all of those things
and so I for the time that we were
together changed myself but I also think
he changed himself because he grew up in
the church yeah yeah yeah one of the
things that has been happiest for me is
seeing him be okay with being gay and
finding a partner that he's going to
spend the left the rest of his life dang
I'm sorry playing oh this is a fake plan
it's not a tomato sorry because if it
was tomato you he would attack on me
um but is to see him be Embrace his full
self yeah and be real about it
you know how many people I know that
have their marriages have ended up in
divorce because man has come out being
gay yeah and the common denominator is a
group in the church
that's why I'm like there has to be a
church where where they love the lgbtqia
community yeah there has to be a church
but we also again in this Society have a
hierarchy of sins if you're gonna blame
somebody for being gay
and call that a sin then you being obese
is a sin yeah
I mean look we're gonna end this podcast
on this but let me tell you about this
[__] dude so I have a guy who I followed
and he's a I'm he's a fighter right and
I grew up watching this guy my whole
life you know I hate when you fight
though I don't like that no it makes me
scared I don't like it either I just got
stuck in the face the other day [__]
hurt but but are you going back 100
idiot I like feeling it I like feeling
the danger there was a dude and he
messages me right so I did this you know
video where I was talking about gain
weight I was asking God like why are you
doing this to me and he starts sending
me scripture he goes you shouldn't use
God's name in vain and he starts
lecturing me and I was like I was a
youth Minister oh let's go crack crack
and I started bringing scripture blah
blah blah admonishing everything that
he'd done so I was like can you
you knock people out for a living and
this was long I was like do you want to
speak Spanish yeah I'll sit down I said
let's speak for your sins right and I
started taking excerpts from the stuff
he did I was like this is what you did
and I started referencing Bible verses
and I took a good two hours to do this
[__] and this [__]
[Music]
I was like don't ever speak to me about
something that you don't know about
right like because he the thing that
pissed me off or that you think you're
gonna come at me from a place of power
let me tell you the thing that pissed me
off it was this one sentence he goes
have you read the Bible you should read
it sometimes and I was like
I've read the Bible probably at least
six times my whole life let's get it
let's talk about it because you're
talking about me with some random words
I see no scripture here so you have no
references if you want to go scripture
for scripture let's [__] go in the
name of God I rebuke thee bam so say it
in the morning
my DMs like bruh
new baby
and cry yeah and then he's over here
talking about is it it's just we love
the new babes of Christ but y'all gotta
calm down like if you ain't if you're
new to this he ain't true to this we
were raised off of pews and this man was
just trying to lecture me and I'm like
listen bro you just got saved shut up
yeah don't talk to me about this type of
stuff and it's like it's easy for you to
throw stones right very easy for you
right but guess what like yeah you could
probably beat my [__] ass but not
through a DM
all right
it's the self-awareness like
maybe if I see you in person you
probably can knock me out but in this DM
it's a KL bro like you gonna be a total
knockout and I just did it through the
grace of God that's all that I did and I
talk facts so what are you gonna do you
gonna beat me up for talking about Jesus
our lord and savior is that what you're
gonna do guess who's going to hell first
maybe he's a new baby in Christ I mean
he's still got some he's still got some
sin on the back of his League this
[__] trying to [__] judge my
faith I never said I was a perfect
Christian you know what I'm saying like
I'm learning I'm getting better but also
even the idea that we can't question God
yeah I think that's what he created he
knows well that's what I said too I
referenced you know people in the Bible
I was like listen you're only going
based off the story of job but you're
not talking job was one person and he
was crazy
like the fact that Joe though he slay me
yeah well I trust him I'm like I got a
favor like do I have faith faith I don't
I don't want to be tested two things I
never pray for them patience because I
don't want you to test me I don't want
you to test me I got must receive Faith
that's enough and I told him this too I
was like you based your story on the
story of Job where God took every
everything from him but he still said
his faith but you forget that unless
your job was one person exactly and you
also forget Judas was also a disciple
back you know facts but but see people
don't even want to recognize the context
right like it was
there were tons of people on earth
and the devil was like well who you who
you gonna let me test his faith in God
chose one person
not many it was one only which means
that job was designed and created to
endure that strife
and you have seen so many things I got a
hell of first world problems and I'm
over here complaining
him being a teacher you know I don't
hate being a teacher but [__] we need
to make more yeah why do we need to make
more because I like expensive things
that's a first world problem am I
starving no I'd rather I drive a Lexus
like clearly I'm not hurting for money
but I want more money because I like
nice things so I'm not Joe I cannot be
joke I already feel like myself I am
joked going to work every day changing
America's future making them better
babysitting yo pay me like a babysitter
pay me 15 an hour per kid I won't say
nothing I literally you know use these
references and I was going to bring my
buddy somebody wants to donate Louie to
me I will take it my buddy Ed was like a
missionary for so many years and I
wanted to send this to him because he
would have went off right and I was like
listen let me just go ahead and give him
a couple of examples right and just like
the idea of him to kind of press his
whole because his main thing is like
there are so many you know trans people
in this world we're finding a spiritual
battle I was like you need to fight the
battle with you right now because you
question my faith I did a comedy video
where I'm talking to God and he goes he
says I'm using his name in vain that's
not using his name in vain you have
conversations with God When you pray
what but you have to have a relationship
to know that yeah and I think that's the
difference right is that a lot of people
have affinities and relationships with
their church but not with God so I
question God all the time especially
last year like you it's not a secret you
know I told you I was like I want to
leave education like I I am sacrificing
too much there's a whole let me tell you
something y'all need to pay teachers
more and some of you parents you
participation ribbon parents need to get
off teachers backs otherwise you're
gonna have classrooms that are 40 to 1
because people are leaving right and so
at the end of last year when I was like
okay I'm gonna stay in teaching and for
me I was like this this group of kids
which I have heard about this group
since they were in kindergarten so it's
not the pandemic can't even blame the
pandemic on it my one of my best teacher
friends
she had them in third grade
and when the pandemic happened
she was you know we're crying oh oh it's
my kid she was like I'm so glad I will
never have to teach these kids again in
person for the rest of my life
right she ends up having to leave our
school we have to close a class
a class opens back up she comes back
she's teaching sixth grade oh Lord
last year fifth grade teaching these
kids I'm like
you know what father is just these kids
I will never have to teach these kids
again
Friday before the school year ends my
principal's like I'm so glad you're
staying I'm going to need you to move up
to sixth grade I was sobbing this office
you know how I felt about this group you
know so I was like
oh I'm job yeah God these were the same
group of kids that made me want to
abandon my career why on Earth would you
give me another year with them and same
for her she was like how is it that I
come back to my home school and I teach
the kids that I was happy to not have to
see every day during the pandemic why
what did I do though ye slay me I'm I'm
kind of down am I trust in you like what
is this bruh and then you hear the other
part of the surgery God never gives you
anything you can't handle oh my gosh I
was like I can't handle this more like
we gotta talk because what you think I
could handle was not the same right
and I need it this year like in
hindsight I need it this year
but I was also like I'm done with
education like this is trash I don't get
paid enough for this and part of the
reasons because they are emotionally
there are emotional vultures they
literally suck everything
and I tell them this I'm like I love
y'all y'all are my babies but I can't
give y'all no more you took everything
y'all have taken everything right
but there's a but then I had teachers
that were like oh but it's
bruh I can still love these kids and say
this is hard as hell man I'll tell you
this like I have a another friend who's
an elementary school teacher and then I
I love hearing her gripe about her [__]
because she needs to let [__] out and
it's just interesting to me right finish
the whole half bottle of wine like you
know sometimes two it's like you know
with people who you work for they also
sometimes forget how stressful your job
is right and they go oh by the way we
have this thing after school can you do
it oh that's funny are you paying me
because that's a lot I mean if you are
I'm spent
dear districts if you ain't paying
teachers to do stuff we're not doing it
for free anymore and they're like stop
using the kids to guilt us oh the kids
will be so excited to see you okay so
then pay me to show up it reminds me of
church oh you you're not doing this for
God's grace
like hey let me tell you something man
the moment we step off of church ground
which is holy grounds I'm socking you up
so don't let me catch you outside these
games don't guilt me I don't do that
don't kill me and they make you feel
like what I was trying to do like a bad
educator yeah or a bad Christian a bad
Christian
right well you're not going to do this
for the grace of God my buddy had told a
story where uh this church that he left
[__] up his relationship with God
because of this he was a videographer
and he did video work they had this huge
thing out in Seattle that was you know
making big money or whatever and he just
asked for his minimum pay
and they were like I'm gonna ask you the
church afterwards and they made him feel
like a piece of [__] because he has to
get paid for work and he wasn't asking
he was asking for a little bit and then
he found out the band everybody every
step of the way got paid a paycheck
except for him and then he was like what
and then luckily he had a leader in the
group that found out and he was like you
didn't get paid and that leader caused
him he was as they should he was like
you [__] took advantage of this young
man you did are you insane and they made
him feel like a shitty Christian because
of it and they don't understand that it
has a ripple effect when it comes to
religion he like it was like the start
that it planted the seed for him to just
denounce God for the foreign that's what
makes me sad is because if you don't
have your individual personal
relationship with God with Christ
outside of the church
people are going to mess up your
relationship because it's gonna happen
people are flawed which means that
people will take advantage people were
like church like church trauma is real I
have church trauma Church trauma is real
you have church trauma right but one of
the best things that I can say is that
in my 20s with leaving the church where
I grew up
I went I joined a church that was hyper
focused on me having a personal
relationship with God yeah
not with the church
getting up I had never heard my pastor
at the time in my 20s he was pastor
Wayne Cheney
and the the message that he preached
that had me join the church
was him apologizing
to the entire the entire congregation
in advance
right he said I'm Gonna Let You Down
I'm flawed I'm not perfect
I'm gonna fall short I'm not gonna be
able to show up to everything there may
be times when I give you counsel and it
may be my humanist talking over my
spirit litness
but I want you to know that God is real
I'm flawed but God's not
so your relationship with God cannot
just be about me it has to be about
you and I really appreciate that too and
you know a lot of people don't ever hear
me talk about religion in this type of
way and you know my attendance in church
but
um like I said don't follow what I do
you know develop your own relationship
with whatever religion that you have
whatever God but again right like your
relationship with Christ is personal
exactly and so I I started seeing this
thing where you know there were churches
in Los Angeles there's a lot of mega
churches here that make a lot of [__]
and I'll go there and people trying to
be influencers trying to be pastors and
I'll I'll go there and I look at the
individuals that attend the church and
they are more about the church and
what's popping there than what their
relationship is with God and I go oh
this is not where I want to be because
it's like it's it's you could see it it
you know you tend enough you could start
to see it and then I start hearing
things that the church say that I just
don't agree with and I go oh you're
scared to lose your money and I've
talked about this before too right where
you know within the Christian religion
what people are going to bring up
anyways they talk about like
homosexuality being a sin which is
that's how it is in the religion right
but it doesn't mean that I can't bring
someone who is homosexual into Christ as
well that's how I see sin that's how I
see it and that's the way that I keep my
the moment you I literally have gotten
into conversation because I grew up not
just Pentecostal but culture yeah yeah
okay so it was you can't wear if you
wear pants as a woman you're sinning if
you dream lunchroom
[Laughter]
Hell My Gana until the day she died will
tell you that Jesus turned the water
into wine because it was unclean I'm
like ganna my God could make it clean he
turned it to Wine because he wanted to
be a turnip right
as so many things even my mom like I
feel like one of the beautiful things
about becoming an adult and from my
mom's telling me that she's not one of
my little friends to her thinking I'm
actually her friend which I'm like I'm
not one of your little friends is the
conversations we're able to have
and part of that is about the rationale
because like I said my mom is highly
educated
I'm highly educated so getting her to
see that drinking is not a sin
right getting her to understand that I
mean you know my mom or she's gonna kill
me for this but my mom wears compression
leggings because she needs support blood
pressure but my mom grew up where when
you were a saved woman you didn't wear
pants so she still put her skirt
but them skirts have gone from being at
her at her Achilles heel you know a
little bit a little bit underneath a
little kneecap chemical kneecap you know
her heels went from flats and they were
at three inches you know why because
it's comfortable and it's hot so it's
okay and that's the thing too and you
know there was a church that I was
attending and one thing I didn't like
was like I don't I also like [__]
[__] made pastors and what I mean by
that is that this guy somebody exactly
what you mean he goes you could ask me
anything and somebody asked so what is
the Christian stance on homosexuality
and instead of saying like in the
Christian religion homosexuality is a
sin but this is how our church deals
with it and we're welcoming and we're
loving he he danced around this
all over I was like you're a [__]
there's a way you could have handled
this and the reason why is because
you're scared of losing your money and I
was like this church is about losing
their money and I started attending the
church more often and every time it was
about money money money I'm like oh this
is weird the prosperity age exactly and
this and I that's when I found out oh
this is the money you get some money he
you know he was talking about the stuff
that he has and I'm like oh this is
weird like this is a very social media s
church and I started looking around and
I see oh this celebrity's here oh this
YouTuber's here oh this oh this is why
this is very popular here you know and
like I said be critical of your religion
think about the things that you wanna
that you really don't agree with and
then look inside yourself like because
you may not want to be a part of it and
under and the thing is that understand
the Bible
right like like I said and I tell people
this all the time the Bible is not only
the book I believe in but it's the
greatest history book that we ever had
right
you have to understand
the mindset
and the time period and understand the
cultural time period understand where it
stands on our timeline of inception of
the world to current you know modern
modern era you have to understand all of
that to take the Bible in as to what it
is because what a lot of Christian
churches do they like to pick and choose
what they talk about
and my thing is look if you're a pastor
you should go to Seminary school you
should study theology you should have a
you need to have some sort of
accreditation that shows that you don't
understand just the Bible but you
understand the history of it all yeah
all the good and the bad all the good
and the bad because in black churches
right you got
two cents
three sins Maybe
one is only for women which is
fornication and I say only for women
because in black churches the woman gets
punished but don't let that man be a
musician she
don't let that man need to like
because he won't get the way that a
woman gets sat down and I've seen it in
the church where I grew up the way that
I've seen women in the church gets sit
down get sat down get penalized for
clinical have a child out of wedlock but
we looking at the baby daddy still
playing on the organ still collecting
that check every Sunday why because he's
you know he's part you feel good what
happens when you're shouting when you're
rejoicing when you're speaking of
tongues you feel good so what do you do
mm-hmm
write a check to the church right so
women in fornication is one
homosexuality is the big one especially
if you're a man can't be homosexual
and pastors love telling the story about
how they was an alcoholic
and they went into they stumbled into
church and then immediately they got
saved the drunkenness
it was your choice don't be drunkenness
was gone and they started living for
Jesus right those are the big three
we also forget about gossiping oh we
forget about pedophilia
we forget about my favorite
obesity because I'm like could have
sworn gluttony was a sin yeah yeah
black church black Christians
so if you gonna point the finger at
someone who identifies as gay and you
gonna point a figure a pointer finger
out of one mother you better look at
them three fingers that are pointing
back at your 400 pounds self
no
because uh because according to the
Bible that I read a sin is a sin
so the same way that you overeat at
night
is as much of a sin as a girl you know
who's creeping with the man that's
telling her that she loves her you know
he's saying I love you is the same as
the person who you know like if we're
gonna call a sin a sin you gotta call it
a sin and by the way too I've never seen
somebody undo their gay ever so I've
been as long as we've been alive I've
never seen it and I have a bunch of gay
friends so sometimes I don't know what
to tell you I don't know what to tell
you either because that's the other
thing too I'm like if we believe that
people can be alcoholics we can believe
that people can be I mean you will come
up with especially in the black
community you will come up for any
reason for somebody to be fat they're
big boned
is genetics are you trying to work out
but then when it comes to being gay
that's magically a choice that's a
spirit that's the same spirit that is
making you obese is uh is making that
person gay and if you don't want to
believe that then it can't be a spirit
you know what I mean so even when I talk
to I was literally having this
conversation on the way up here it's so
funny is having a conversation with why
I support the human rights of the
lgbtqia community qia plus is because
I'm like
I as a human I look at it like this at
one point interracial marriage was
illegal
at one point black Americans get that's
why we jump over the Broom the whole
reason why we jump over the broom is
because that was the signifying of the
marriage because we could not legally be
married
right we live in us we live in a culture
where our very own existence something
that we I cannot change that I was born
black I cannot change the color of my
skin that was illegal that was the sin
Mormons believe we didn't have a soul
we could not go to heaven we didn't have
a soul so how am I as a person who has
come from a lineage and currently lives
in a society where my civil liberties
are always being threatened then go and
threaten somebody else's you know the
100 and the weird my dad said it the
best he goes
you telling gay people that they can't
get married doesn't change the fact that
they're gay
okay
doesn't change the fact that they're gay
so what's the problem
yeah I mean my father's a pastor he just
didn't see the logic behind it because
it's illogical because anybody that
thinks with common sense is going to say
imagine imagine a world
do like this was crazy do you remember
the first girl you were attracted to
well probably not I mean I don't
remember the first man I was attracted
to absolutely thinking actually I do it
was Will Smith
that I'm like
I didn't I was five years old the first
time I was watching Fresh Prince of
Bel-Air and I was like oh I like him
I don't know where that came from that
wasn't a choice yeah I looked at the
screen saw Will Smith being fine
I still love you even after the slap
fine and was like I like that yeah so
your dad is on point because I could
have easily been like
Hillary Banks I like that
you don't turn gay it's not a choice and
I think that's the thing that people
we've been taught so long to demonize
people that don't have that don't fall
in line with
the Mass Appeal of thought right which
is why Blackness is is bad being black
because that that's the com being black
is the complete and antithesis of being
white yeah being homosexual is the same
antithesis as being gay or being
non-binary or being non-gender
conforming is the antithesis of what we
are taught has been normed and so the
way that people have to
swallow it and it and and not accept it
because they're not willing to accept it
is to denounce it it's to denounce it as
others and that's the truth and I'm like
if I don't want my civil liberties
infringed on how dare I infringe on
somebody else's what it boils out to me
I just don't give a [__] you live your
life and I live my life back don't let
it come creep over here and try to [__]
up my [__] I won't [__] up your [__] no
facts and it's like people try to you
know people try to say
well
well um I hear this argument a lot which
is like oh well do you want somebody
transgendered going into the bathroom
with McKenna or Devin
I don't care because there's a
difference between somebody being
transgendered and being a pedophile yeah
yeah yeah a pedophile means that you're
preying on children and you are
infringing on that child's civil liberty
so I'm all about people having their own
civil liberties and their human rights
without infringing on others yeah you've
seen a gun owner is infringing on my
civil liberties because I have to worry
about you having some crazy
here's the hard part like that's the
person that's gonna assume yeah this is
so new for everybody so it's like like I
said there's too many absolutists right
so
I understand I'm listening and I'm
understanding kind of like both sides to
it right so it's like yeah we do see
these examples so like okay would you
want that's a question to have right
like would you want somebody who is
transgender to be it's like if I were to
be honest probably not but what are they
doing if they're just taking a piss then
you're just taking a piss and if you see
yourself as a woman or a guy or whatever
whatnot then maybe that's not a big
issue right
but then they all know what you're doing
in the stall yeah and then like the
other part is is like and they have
issues with sports which I probably
understand a little more you know sports
sports I agree with there's a little
clear line to that you know like I I
definitely wouldn't want my daughter
[__] I don't know playing ball with
some dude just dunking on her ass 24 7
[__] her up you know what I'm saying
this [__] and he just you know a
dude comes out thick ass Adam's Apple
big ass [__] legs who's like woman up
[__] like all right hold on a second
bro or ma'am so that I agree with why
and even if that is it that may be a
flaw mentality but that's why I cross
the line is with sports I'm like now
baby
I understand that you want to be called
shikisha
but Shamar
you have the legs
of a 15 year old boy and you're six foot
seven
and you're six for seven so no you
cannot play against the Whitney High
School basketball girls where our point
guard is five foot five we can't do that
Shamika like I love you boo shakima I
forgot what I named him you got you got
to play in your own sports and that
could be flawed that could be flawed as
hell right but I'm also like I'm not
perfect so even within my new even
within my ability to like Advocate I'm
still learning how to be an advocate for
things that don't directly affect me
yeah like I said like
people have asked to specifically emails
it's like what do you think about this
specifically because the Hot Topic right
now is transgendered things and I'm like
listen I'll be honest with you right now
all I'm seeing are headlines and I'm not
going to base my opinions on anything
based on headlines I could tell you how
I feel about stuff but right now it'd be
super out of pocket because I haven't
thought about it at all to be honest
with you and you're just asking to make
content about a Hot Topic which by the
way that's all this stuff is it's hot
constant Hot Topics you see the [__]
Budweiser [__] you know why they did
that because it's a Hot Topic nobody
gives a [__] about this [__] money you
know what I'm saying and then now we're
like cherry picking things of like the
worst examples of people in the
transgender Community right and using
that as the motto yeah it's like but
then once again I'm saying this from my
personal experience never met no it's
not sure I have it's not that I haven't
met I've never sat down and have a few
people in my inner circle who are
transgendered so I wouldn't really
[__] know I have no Nuance to this
right so I can only talk to you about
what I see online and but if I do that
I'm not doing any good and it's not a
topic I really care to discuss because I
actually don't give a [__] about it
right and that's hard to say why don't
you give a [__] about it because
sometimes it says it's okay to say I
don't know
it's okay to say I don't know yeah and
then for me to assess and then come back
later right now I just don't know it's
so [__] new and fresh and you're
expecting me to think and say things in
absolutes and I don't have that for you
and it's a bit interesting having
students and former students that are
transgendered or non-binary because
for me I've always I've already
developed that love for them
so I'm like well if you don't have a
pronoun if you don't want to identify by
a gender conforming pronoun and you want
to identify as they
call you they isn't going to kill me
yeah it's not gonna kill me so I don't
have to understand it
and I think that's part of the problem
that we have with Humanity right is that
you feel like you have to have
experienced or witnessed something for
it to be true it's not the same you know
what the crazy [__] is too it's like now
I'm hearing younger people saying like
no you not understanding it is just is
worse yeah so I can't just respect you
as a human being it's like and I think
that and I think that is where we are
becoming grave right it's because I will
never know what it's like to you can't
expect to be homosexual I will never
know I can be an ally to the lgbtqia
community plus as best as I can be and I
will do that but it's the same thing as
you being white and transgender isn't
the same as being a black woman yeah but
you don't need to understand it to
support me
just know that when I say this this is
my truth and support me in my truth
that's all that it is right all that it
is like I'll be telling people too it's
like I'll even boil it down to this you
will most likely even no matter how many
years pass get people in the majority of
the world if you are somebody who are
transgender this has something I thought
about where you'll get every person to
believe that you are what you say that
you are but what you can do is make sure
that they treat you respectfully and
understand that that's how you feel but
you cannot dictate how that person feels
about you in anything not just your your
race your religion how you feel what you
like to eat anything like that so when
that becomes the battle that's going to
be an uphill battle that you will
forever lose because now you're telling
somebody not me specifically how they
should [__] feel about you rather
than just saying hey can you be
respectful of me and just use my
pronouns I think we should leave it like
that we should because I always tell
people it's none of my I've in trying to
heal myself or being a people pleaser
I'm also like is none of my business how
you feel about me yeah
all you got to do is treat me with
respect that's it especially if you're
not somebody that I know well you're not
somebody that's in my closed Circle
you're not somebody that I depend on as
a part of my Village
pay treat me with respect what you say
about me behind closed doors is your
business but what you do in front of my
face is my business and just don't let
me hear it and don't let me hear it
don't let me hear it if you want to call
me some black B behind closed doors do
that but to my face
keep it respectful keep it respectful
because you died in my circle anyway who
the [__] cares what you do outside of my
circle is what you do that is actually
freeing right yeah I don't understand it
though people don't know about that they
don't get that they don't
but how come let them do whatever they
do outside they're you're not my friend
anyways you know what I'm saying but you
are human beings I think that is what
comes with every person that calls
himself an advocate or somebody that's
trying to push
a movement forward is that one of the
things that will release you and
actually bring you
peace because I was struggling I have
high anxiety I have general anxiety
disorder which means it don't take much
to make my to give me a panic attack
right but one of the things I was
freeing was being like it's none of my
business what you say about me behind
closed doors what matters to me is what
you say to my face yeah
I understand I don't trust everybody I
understand that not everybody has my
best interest I understand that I'm not
going to be everybody's cup of tea and I
don't want to be yeah but at least face
to face because if you don't pay me
respect face to face you're gonna be the
one that's on the short end of the stick
cause I'm not standing for that yeah
like I I'll even put it like this like
you know because I'm in entertainment
and I see it happen so many times where
somebody will say something nice to
somebody's face and they'll say
something else wise it's a hundred
percent of people entertainment if
you're an actor you've already done this
I already know don't even say you don't
do this [__]
um and it's it was a hard thing for me
to see right because so many people in
entertainment or maybe in Los Angeles in
and of itself they love saying like
that's my brother that's my sister so
quick to say that [__] you don't even
know that's what I said for real like
it's got to be for real yeah like you
don't know these people and you're like
oh my God this is I love you for life
you love them you just met them what the
[__] are you talking about this is
nonsense right and they go and this
person who they think that they
outwardly say these specific adjectives
about this person that they do something
Sly right and they go I can't believe
you did this why you don't know them so
what the [__] are you talking about tell
them but I think that's the thing though
is that people understand the difference
between Fast Friends tried and true
friends and connection
right like there's levels to it hell
yeah there's people that you turn up
with
the people that you turn up with you
ain't meeting my kids you're not meeting
my kids and we have talked about this
right like you may not you're not the
person I'm gonna call to when I'm down
and out yeah if I'm at LAX and I need a
ride you're definitely not picking me
you're not the person I get it you're
not the person and even for me something
that has been
eye-opening is having to acknowledge
that
people that I have 20 years with
you just to turn up yeah
and 20 years of being turned up and
that's not a problem either it's not a
problem it's just levels to it yeah it's
all that it is like we whenever we see
each other we're [__] drunk we don't
actually share anything personal with
each other anyways like I've had some
stuff too on the other side when people
come up and they're like it's Uncle
David I'm not Uncle T ugly ass kid the
[__] are you talking about that's a baby
to me that's a baby that I see I am not
that child's Uncle as I say hi to Uncle
David don't say that
don't say that because I don't care
about you that way so I don't care about
your child that way I haven't seen your
daughter I love your kid because I love
you that's all that it is right and you
are McKenna's Uncle David there it is
and Devin's Uncle David because there's
love there there's there's a connection
There's real relationship there we've
actually never turned that together how
old is Devin though oh my gosh Devon is
15 he's 5 11. that's great so I'm gonna
talk some [__] he gonna have to back me
up I'm like are you big enough cool but
you know what is even crazier is like
watching him and so like McKenna just
turned four so when Hunter and I first
got together Devin was three wow so now
McKenna's like transitioning into the
age where I started watching Devin grow
up so it was crazy to see the difference
between them yeah and I just can't
believe oh my gosh I cannot believe that
he is 15
4.0 student playing back baseball like
working his heart out and I'm like damn
do the four pointers show off damn
that's crazy but the thing is is that
I'm like dude he's a really dope human
being like even if he wasn't my kid
he is empathetic he is
he is celebratory people not tolerant
he's celebratory he's understanding
and even there's times when you know
like I will be like oh my gosh white
people exhaust me he was like don't say
that they're not all the same I'm like
[__] shut up but I'm also like but I
raise you to be understanding of this
right and that's dope as a parent
especially the teacher he has to talk
back but he got to whisper a little bit
he's like don't say that oh he
definitely can't learn
you know and it's also like Grace to
giving Grace to your kids
because he's a dope human being but I
also understand that we won't see eye to
eye on everything and that's okay he's
an individual now too he's an individual
and that is a hard place to come to us a
parent but it's a dope place because I'm
like look I understand and that's part
of the reason why I said earlier I wish
my mom wouldn't have given everything to
my sister and I because
and I'm sure you feel the same way like
moms of the 80s and the 90s their
friends were their children's parents
friends
and I'm like my dad had to suffer
because of that yeah and I'm like you
know I never saw my mom do anything for
herself
so in in becoming a mother
you know I became a bonus mom at 26.
so I sacrificed so many things because I
thought that would that's what made me a
good mother and yes motherhood counts as
a sacrifice but one of my biggest
regrets was thinking that I shouldn't go
on trips with my girlfriends or do
things with my friends because oh you
know Devin can't go and so now at 30
something Devin and McKenna's mama is
very different because I'm like I want
especially having a daughter I'm like I
want McKenna to see me having healthy
friendships with my girlfriends that
I've been friends with since I was 5 12
14. I want her to miss mommy when Mommy
goes on a trip because when she's a mom
I want her to do the same thing for
yourself yeah yeah I want her to you
know like even when it comes to her dad
like there's times when I'm kissing
Hunter and she'll be like that's my
daddy I said that's my husband and he
will always choose me before you because
when you get married your husband should
always choose you before your kids all
your kind I would have said be quiet
your leftovers
be quiet
one of the best things that my that we
went through in premarital counseling
and I feel like I told you this too was
the fact that like your kids are not
yours forever oh yeah 100 my mom knows
that she taught me that yeah your kids
should choose their spouse over you
because biblically speaking your family
is the person that you are sharing a
covenant with god with
right and like even in the ups and downs
of marriages like the person who I am
now is not the person I was when Hunter
and I got together it's not the person
that I was when I married him it's not
the person that I that I gave that I was
when I gave birth yeah right but that's
the person I choose to do life with yeah
yeah yeah yeah I don't choose to do life
with my kids at 18 there's a reason why
your kids are leave the nest and go off
to college because that's their
self-discovery of themselves Devin is
three years away from that
and it's terrifying and it's scary but I
also oh I didn't tell you about this
story time
so I went back to Whitney this is when I
first realized Devin is not mine
he is mine but he's not mine so I went
to Whitney for International Day right
so I'm there to see my mentors young
black Scholars they're flourishing
they're performing at International day
okay
so I get a tap on my shoulder now mind
you not only am I Whitney alone but I
have a decent number of students that
are also at Whitney and so sometimes I
meet their friends and their friends are
like oh my gosh you're Mrs Mitchell you
know my friend so-and-so said that
you're their favorite teacher so maybe
the top of my shoulder little black girl
I cannot remember what she looks like
but I I know she's black she Taps on my
shoulder she's like what's your name
and I was like
it's not even the disrespectful part I'm
like oh Megan Mitchell Mrs Mitchell
before I can get out anything else right
she goes I'm talking to your son my I
felt like Ricky in the drive-by shooting
like I was like wow
I'm talking to your son
I was just texting him
and he said that she was gonna be here
and so I was wondering if that was you
and runs off
I thought I was a cool mom this was when
I realized I wasn't a cool mom
because one I wanted to fight her mama
because why did why didn't your mama
teach you how to talk to adults I don't
care what what J's I'm wearing I don't
care how I dress I don't care about the
braids and the earrings I'm still old
enough to be somebody's mama so you
still need to talk to me with respect
right but then two your mama didn't tell
you
that you don't just walk up to
to a guy's mom that you're interested in
and said I'm talking to your son first
of all
luckily the relationship I have with
Devin James Mitchell we already knew I
didn't know what she looked like but I
knew that he had a little girl or that
he had a little girl that he like kind
of liked or whatever right I don't even
like the fact that she touched me
neither but I'm also like don't even do
this you don't but you don't even know
if Devin told me about you
so you're trying to state claim over my
son not knowing if he's told me about
you not knowing the relationship there
there were so many things that were
wrong on this level right
but she then messaged Devin and told
Devin I don't think your mom likes me
so he's calling me I'm taking McKenna to
see Disney on Ice he's calling me I call
him an intermission hey son he was like
yeah what's up Mumu I was like nothing
baby what's going on he was like yeah
um baby girl said that she met you today
I said oh yeah she I definitely met her
he was like yeah she like said you
didn't like her but I can't figure out
why so that's why I love my son because
my son knows me
so I said well I don't dislike her
because I don't know her but did she
make a favorable impression she didn't
this is why
he was like she did what
why he was like why would she even go up
to you and I said
I don't know but you need to go talk to
her but all but no I didn't even say
that I was like I don't know because
there was no reason for her to do that
which there wasn't she went out of her
way I'm talking with my mentees these
are these are girls that I have
relationships with for years since we
developed the uh the mentorship program
she came out of her way
and then he was like and then she tapped
you and said she tapped me also he knows
then she said and I know because I told
her yeah I'm saying like he knows yeah
so he's no of course Devin also has been
raised to talk to people yeah I'm
talking to your son he was like oh I was
like this is what she said
and he and so that ended very shortly
afterwards and I didn't have to say
anything to him like I didn't have to
tell him I didn't have to go into detail
what I thought because we raised him to
know how to speak to somebody but that
was also when I realized
Devin's not mine yeah
he's not my baby anymore
you know like he is developing
relationships with girls do I think that
this girl clearly she's not a forever
girl but there is going to be one girl
that's going to be his forever
or maybe it'll be a boy you know but
but Devin identifies as being
heterosexual so his forever currently is
going to be a girl
and when he gets with that girl
he has to choose that girl over me yeah
because Hunter his daddy can't choose
his mom or his stepmom over me I got to
be the one with McKenna McKenna is gonna
have to choose her husband over her
daddy
and that's just how it is
so
so Hunter better choose me over them
because that one day these little [__]
Gonna choose
um for anybody that is offended
I'm black so I don't care whatever like
get over your offense
you can't counsel me because I don't
want to be popular anyway so peace but
these they gonna choose their little
spouse
over over their father and myself
I mean my mom already told me too like
when you know when I was dating Mario
early on she goes you know like the
hardest part about being a parent or a
mother is that I have to understand that
you
the the life that you build with this
person that
she is going to be more important than I
am right and you know for her to say
they actually kind of hurt me I was like
no no you're more important she goes no
no that's not how it's supposed to work
that's not how and I think that's what's
great about your mom yeah she's like is
this it's not it's not how it's supposed
to be she goes because you're going to
have kids with this person and she knew
this because of her relationship with
her mother-in-law with my grandma in the
beginning wasn't that great but he's
just like one of the things that your
father did really well was that even
though we would fight we would we would
get into it with each other if his mom
my grandmother came in and said
something bad about me he would be like
no that's my wife yeah this is a
conversation I've had with my wife you
don't get to say that about her and my
dad drew that hard line he goes so I
will never ever you'll never hear me say
a bad thing about your wife ever as long
as you guys are together and you guys
are having a healthy relationship all
your fights I'm just an outside person
you'll never ever hear me say something
bad about it and she under she
understands that because she knows what
it feels like because it's terrible the
same yeah so that's I mean hoops
and Mario's very fortunate too because I
think she said it to me she goes
actually very lucky that your mom is not
what I expected because she's not the
typical Korean
um mother-in-law which is like when you
come in here you bow you do the dishes
with me all that stuff my mom's like
don't [__] touch the dishes go sit
and chill hang out you know you they
were supposed to go out and then she
goes no no my mom's like stop touching
my [__] you know what I mean [__]
relax like I'm not your typical
mother-in-law don't expect that out of
me so just move on and so you know she
Muriel's very fortunate my mother-in-law
have an amazing my mother in love I
Mamacita we have an amazing relationship
but baby I had to prove myself tenfold
and thousand times over it was hard yeah
yeah yeah and I didn't understand
because I was like Hunter you not going
through this grief when my family walked
you with open arms and you the one
that's bringing the kids I was nervous
because I was like oh my gosh she has a
kid he's never been married how's my
family going to judge him they didn't
judge him at all versus me I'm like no
kids good credit I you know have amazing
head on my shoulders have a good job and
face all the judgment
right but I also
we are amazing now and I know that they
love me unconditionally now but Hunter
and I've been together for almost 12
years and it I could say for a solid
seven it was very touch and go you know
but I'm glad that your mom realizes that
because that's the same way that I feel
about whoever Devin's gonna marry is
that I'm like
you know if this is I have to trust my
son
to know that if he is bringing somebody
to us this is somebody that he values
also too it's like you can't hold the
kid's hand forever no you know you're
not going to be around forever either so
it's like they just have to live their
life and you know up until this point
you can do your best and you still give
it advice still guide them the right way
but as adults and as their individuality
comes in they have to make the choices
themselves and it's like because if you
start doing this thing too where and
this by the way bleeds into friendship
as well you start feeling that oh
because I gave this person they didn't
do it they're dumb it's like no you can
only do what you can do you can only do
what you can do you can only control the
only actions that you actually have full
control over are your own
that's it and you know that is it when
they're 18 15 16 17 they're in the value
individual value really comes in and you
acts only hope that they love and
respect you to a certain point and
there's gonna be points where you still
get mad at them still gonna be upset and
I say this now in the flashback I'm over
here socking my kid in the face but like
I'm gonna remind you though
[__] choke this child and I'll
be like I'm coming tell them to come
outside just put their stuff on the curb
imma get them for a day or two yeah
that's the truth I'll [__] kill this
child oh my gosh I have to pee oh yeah
go ahead where's
right over here we'll just wrap the
podcast here anyways anyways guys we can
talk for [__] hours
yeah uh you can catch Jesus brain every
Sundays at 12 p.m you guys know what it
is uh shout outs to Megan for coming
through we were talking about some deep
ass [__] I love her to death uh genius
at 12 p.m see y'all next time peace